Today I want to talk a little about
security. I don't have to mention this
but from the name you can derive that
security of an application and in our
context security of a backend
application is one of the most important
things that you as an engineer should be
aware of. I'm not saying that all the
other topics that I covered in this
playlist are not important, but security
is something which if you don't pay a
lot of attention to has a lot of
destructive effects on your application.
Destructive financially and when it
comes to your business, when it comes to
your resources and in turn everything
boils down to money and finance. But
security itself is a huge domain. You
can talk about different aspects of
security depending on which context
you're talking about. We can talk about
browser security which will talk a lot
about HTML and your cookies, local
storage, all these different components
where vulnerabilities can arise. We can
also talk about your network security
which means the transition layer with
the HTTP, HTTPS and your encryption,
compression all these components come.
We can also talk about server security.
I'm not talking about backend security
where we are only concerned about our
app our particular code base and our
particular process which will be running
inside an operating system. When I say
server security I mean the operating
system in itself when we deploy a
backend code in a server we deploy our
particular application which runs in a
process inside an operating system. So
that operating system itself has a
security context. You can talk about
that also. And obviously we can also
talk about our back end which means all
the vulnerabilities that can arise
because of our app because of the code
that we have written in our back end.
And if you start to tackle and if you
start to discuss security in all these
context, it quickly goes out of the
scope. You don't need to know all these
things about security. Of course, it is
always better if you are aware of these
things. If you are interested in these
things, there are a lot of reading
materials that you can find with just a
simple Google search. But for this video
where we mostly talk about practical
things where we mostly talk about things
that are in the context of backend
engineering. In this context we have to
limit ourselves to a particular set of
vulnerabilities a particular set of
rules that we should follow to ensure
security of our application. And the
last thing that I want to mention before
we start this video is the aim the
purpose of this video is not to teach
you all the different fancy security
techniques in one video so that you can
just go ahead and implement all of them
in your application starting from
tomorrow. That is obviously not going to
happen. As I have mentioned security is
a vast domain and you have to do a lot
of reading yourself. You have to do a
lot of research. We have to build the
mindset to build a truly secure
application. That sentence itself does
not make any sense because no
application can ever be truly secure. As
technology evolves, as our libraries
evolve, as our programming languages
evolve, there will always be security
vulnerabilities. But anyway, we have to
try our best. So the purpose of this
video is not to teach you fancy security
techniques. As I have already mentioned
in my authentication and authorization
video, the goal of this video is to make
you paranoid about your application,
about the code that you write and give
you a mindset to always keep security in
the back of your head whenever you are
creating any kind of application. So
that is the purpose that is the goal of
this video. Of course, we are going to
talk about a lot of security threats, a
lot of security based techniques to
prevent all these threats. We'll also
look at a few demos to understand how it
works on code level etc etc. But again
if I miss some major component when it
comes to security if I miss talking
about a major threat or some best
practice then as I've said security is
huge and as long as you are able to get
this mindset that always keep security
at the back of your head whenever you
are writing code then I will consider
this video as successful. So with that
we can start. One of the things that I
have thought a lot about structuring
this video is I don't want to list and I
don't want to talk about a fixed list of
very abstract vulnerabilities because
that never works. Instead what I want to
do is I want to give you a glimpse of
how to think like an attacker. I don't
want to use the word hacker because
there is a lot of cringe already
associated with the word. So we are
going to use the word attacker for this.
And the fact is these attackers, people
who wish harm upon your application in
any way possible, they don't really care
about the framework, the library, the
programming language that you have
written. They only care about this one
question. The question is where did the
developer make an assumption? That is
the most important question and we are
going to pay a lot of attention to this
question to find out why this question
is so important especially in the
context of security because every single
vulnerability that we are going to talk
about in this video it all comes down to
that single thing. A developer assumed
that the input coming from the user
coming from the front end would be
clean. Or they assumed that the user was
who they said they were. Or they assumed
that the request that they are receiving
on their server on their back end was
coming from their front end the front
end that they are supposed to serve. And
they assume that no one would open the
network tab like this. and no one will
just take a look at the network calls
and no one will try to modify the
parameters. Of course, these assumptions
they feel reasonable when you are
building under deadline, right?
Especially in startups, there is always
a deadline. You want to ship features as
fast as possible. You want to meet the
client's requirements as fast as
possible. In that environment, it is
perfectly reasonable to make all these
assumptions because you are always
thinking in the happy path. The user
will always fill the form correctly, the
way that you are expecting them to. They
will always click the right buttons and
they will always navigate your app the
way they are meant to. But unfortunately
attackers again people who wish harm
upon your application they don't use
your app the way you want them to. They
try to poke at every single boundary.
They try to modify. They try to break
every single input and they try to guess
every one of your assumptions. So by the
end of this video, you'll have a mental
model for thinking about security that
will stick with you regardless of what
language or framework that you're using.
It can be Go, it can be Python, it can
be NodeJS, it can be Rust, does not
matter. You'll always start questioning
this question which is what could go
wrong here in terms of security every
time you write code. With that, let's
jump into our first kind of attacks that
I want to talk about, which are say
injection attacks. Now, injection
attacks, I'll come back to why we are
calling them injection attacks, but they
have been around for decades now. And
and they're still very common and they
all share the same root cause. And once
you start looking at the root cause,
once you start understanding the root
cause, you'll start understanding an
entire category of vulnerabilities. So
let's start with a very fundamental
truth, a very fundamental fact which is
your application speaks multiple
languages. So if let's say this is our
app and let's say here we have database
and this side we have browser and in
this side let's say we have operating
system. We have our app let's say this
is our backend application and at all
times we have to imagine that our
application speaks multiple languages
for multiple contexts. When our app, our
back end tries to query some data, tries
to insert some data, tries to delete
some data, any kind of interaction with
data, it tries to speak to a database,
right? It is a kind of interaction and
for that it uses the language SQL. Same
way assuming that our back end also
deals with sending static assets like
JavaScript or HTML or CSS, then it also
speaks these languages, right? HTML and
CSS and whenever our back end needs to
perform some task in the context of
operating system let's say it wants to
open some kind of file which deals with
the system calls which are governed by
the operating system then it speaks the
language of shell shell script if you're
aware of so of course there will be
other categories here depending on how
big your back end is but the point is at
all times Your back end speaks multiple
languages in multiple contexts and each
one of these languages. They have their
own grammar and their own set of special
characters, their own way of separating
commands from data. And this is where
most of the vulnerabilities come from.
Let's say we are as a user, we are here
because we interact with our back end
through browsers, right? Here is a user.
Most of the time the vulnerabilities
arise because a user speaks one
language. Let's say this is HTML,
JavaScript and CSS because we mostly
talk to browsers, right? Whenever a user
speaking one language tries to cross the
boundary of another language from
starting from here, we interacted
through browsers and the browser
interacted with our back end. And when
this language tries to cross the
boundary and starts entering this
boundary or this boundary in those cases
mostly vulnerabilities appear and we'll
talk about what we call them but skill
injection excss attacks these are one of
the examples of when vulnerabilities
arise because of one user crossing the
boundary from one language to another
because the input from the user in one
particular language they can mean some
kind of special command some kind of
special character in the other language
and that is the root cause of most of
these injection based attacks. So let's
talk about one of the most dangerous and
also common injection attacks which is
SQL injection. Okay, for this let's
imagine a simple login page. We have a
login page here. We have the email
field. We have the password field and
this is running in our browser. This is
governed by our browser. This is our
front end and this is going to talk to
our server which in turn is going to
talk to our database DB. This is our
setup. The user enters the email and the
password. Your server receives these two
fields email and password. It makes a
request to your database to find if the
user exists for this and it checks
whether the password is matching or not.
If it does then it returns a response
right very straightforward. Now what we
want to do we want to zoom in on what
exactly is the database query here. So
let's say this is the database query
that got executed. This is the database
query. If you are familiar with SQL that
is great. It is a very straightforward
SQL query. We want to fetch all the
users whose email is matching this
particular user input. whatever we are
receiving from the user. But if you are
not familiar with SQL, this basically
means that our server is asking our
database that give me the user with this
particular email address, whatever email
address that the user has sent us
through our front end. If the developer
who is building this query by
concatenating strings here the way that
is done here by concatenating strings
taking the query template and just
dropping the user input here inside the
query then we have a huge problem. Now
to understand that problem let's first
discuss the happy path. As I have
already mentioned, most of the times we
assume the happy path. The users are
going to act like the way we are
expecting them to. So let's first do
that. The user comes, let's say the
user's email address is Alice
atgmail.com.
They type their email and they type
their password or whatever the password
is and they send it to our server. Now
given this particular SQL query, we
paste it here. When our server receives
this particular email address, what we
do? We take this email and we inject it
here. Now this will become Alice
whatever@gmail.com.
The server constructs this particular
SQL query. It sends to our database and
the database is able to find a user with
this particular email. It returns it and
the server finds the user and allows the
user to login. Right? That is our happy
path. Everything works perfect. We don't
have to worry about anything. Now let's
talk about not so happy path which is
the attempt of our attacker. So instead
of typing a very valid email, what the
attacker does? They do something like
this. They type a single quote. Then
they type the word or. Then a space.
Then another single quote. Inside there
is one. Another single quote. Equals to
another single quote. There is one.
Another single quote. Then hyphen
hyphen. This is the input that the
attacker types in the email field and
they send it to our server. Now what
happens? As usual, the server takes this
input and inserts it into this whatever
template that it is constructing for the
database query. In order to understand
this, let's go to a DB explorer which
will be much clearer. This is our
template for the first case when we are
talking about our happy path. This is
what it becomes. Let's add a colon here
and here select star from users where
email this becomes let's comment this
out just for our reference and this
becomes after constructing the query
becomes alisgmail.com
this was our happy path same way let's
copy template and paste it here now
let's talk about what the attacker did
after constructing the query this is
what the query will become. We already
had a pair of single quotes here which
was added by the server. Now what
happens inside that we concatenate
whatever the input that we're receiving
for the email. Now what the attacker did
first they typed a single quote single
quote then space let's type space it was
or then single quote 1 equals to single
code 1 then space hyphen hyphen. Right?
This becomes our final query. When we
take this this whole thing and we insert
inside our template where we fetch the
user information. In order to test this
out, let's go ahead and create a table
called users. Users, it will have two
columns. Let's call the first one name
with the data type text and the second
one will be email. Again, text. Let's
end the statement here and let's go
ahead and run it. This table is created.
Now let's insert some data into this
table. Insert to users name email. The
values will be first set is going to be
Alice with the email alice atgmail.com.
The second set will be the name Bob with
the email Bobgmail.com.
Okay. End this with a semicolon. And
let's run this. We have inserted two
rows and if we do a refresh here and
check in our users table. Let me try to
increase the font for this data table.
Let's make this yeah should be fine.
Padding also
sidebar also. Let's increase it. And a
little bit of padding. This is too much.
Anyway, this should do it. Let's make
this a little bigger. Great. Now we have
a users table with two users named Alice
and Bob with the email alice@gmail.com
and bobgmail.com. Now going back to our
SQL query. If we run this query, this
particular query, let's go ahead and run
this. We are getting this particular row
as a result. Since we are saying give us
all the users from the users table where
email matches this exact string which is
alice@gmail.com. That's why we are
getting this row with all the columns as
a result. Now this one is our malicious
query which if you go back to our board.
This was our template and what it does
it takes the user input and inserts it
in between a pair of single quotes. And
since the user passed this particular
statement which is single quote or 1
equals to 1 and hyphen hyphen we take
that and insert it into our template.
This is what the query becomes. And what
happens if we run this? Let's go ahead
and run this. We got all the rows in our
users table. Both Alice and Bob, even
though the user did not pass any email,
but they were able to get a list of all
the users in our database including
their email address. Now let's
understand what exactly happened here.
Starting from our template, our query
template. This is what it is in the
first part which is select star from
users where email equals to single
quote. Okay. And opening single quote.
After this point, this is the user's
input. This is what gets dropped in. And
if we take a look at this input, the
first character is a single quote. And
since the first character is a single
quote, what it does? It closes this
particular pair. Since we already had a
single set of single quote and combined
with the single quote coming from the
malicious input. Now this pair is
complete. Now what this statement
becomes? This statement becomes select
star from users where email equals to an
empty string. This is the first part of
the statement which is a complete logic.
We want to fetch all the emails from our
database where email equals to an empty
string. Of course, email will not be an
empty string in our database, but that's
what leads us to our second part of the
statement. Then we have an or statement.
And as the name suggests, or simply
means either this or this, right? This
first part is the left side of or and
this one is the right side of or. So
let's take a look at the right side of
or. We have one equals to one. not one
as a number one as a character since
they are inside single quotes which
basically says that is the string one
equals to the string one and the answer
is obviously yes so this part of the
statement becomes true and then there is
another clever part which is two hyphens
and we use two hyphens in SQL to comment
out whatever comes after that in that
line and since we have a pair of hyphens
here whatever comes after this which is
a single quote that gets commented out.
If they did not provide this pair of
hyphens, then this will throw an error
because there's an extra single quote
here which obviously creates a syntax
error in SQL. Now what happens to our
final query? This part was the left part
of the or and this is the right part of
the or. Now if you translate it into
English what it means what it is trying
to say is return me all the users from
our database whose email is empty string
which is obviously false or when 1
equals to 1 which is always true since
one part of the or statement is true.
This whole statement becomes true. That
is the clever part of this injection.
And since this whole statement becomes
true this part executes. Now essentially
what it becomes if we come here let's
say we copy this and we paste it here.
Let's say comment it out. If we take
this statement this whole statement and
make this true and we close it and we
run this then we get all the rows in our
database from the users table. And if
you want to shorten it even a little
more since this is only a true condition
here which is a constant rule, we can
take this also and paste it here. Let's
comment this out. And we can just go
ahead and remove this part. And if you
run this select star from users which
returns all the users from our database.
So the idea behind writing this
malicious input is tricking our string
concatenation logic into taking a set of
characters which when combined with our
string combined with our SQL template
which is selecting a set of users from
our database that creates a constant
true condition which in turn makes the
whole statement exclude the where part
and it essentially becomes select star
from users. That's why the attacker is
able to get all the users from our
system with this input with just a
single set of malicious characters. The
characters themselves are not malicious.
When combined with our SQL template,
they become malicious with just this set
of characters. They were able to fetch
all the users from our databases. And
since in our case, the users table only
has name and email. But in a production
database, users table usually has a lot
of fields. Fields like hashed,
passwords, addresses, phone numbers, and
lot of sensitive user informations. But
that is still not as harmful as the next
one. So imagining the same statement,
the same SQL template. Let's get rid of
this and let's remove the comment here.
Instead of passing this, what if they
changed their command and made it more
harmful? What they can do? So let's
remove this part. This is our
essentially the template. Whatever the
user passes, we are embedding it inside
this. So starting from here, let's say
they again did the same trick which is
passing a single quote. Now this part is
complete. So whatever they pass in the
next part that becomes their primary
attack command and after this let's say
they passed a semicolon then they passed
this drop table users and then another
semicolon then again hyphen hyphen so
that this part gets commented out and it
does not throw a syntax error or there
are no other conditions after this
statement which is messing with their
attack command. Now tracing this part
what it essentially becomes if you can
guess which is very straightforward.
This part of the query is obviously
select star from users where email uh is
an empty string. That part is not going
to become true because email is not
going to be an empty string because
usually we have a not null constraint on
our email fields. But this part, this
statement when it's executed, this
completely deletes the users table from
our database. We'll talk about how to
mitigate this. Of course, the first
obvious thing is parameterized queries
which we'll talk about just after this.
But the second obvious prevention for
this is usually in our application code
in our backend code when we establish a
connection to our database to interact
with our database to perform operations
like create update delete and insert
etc. The credential that we use the user
and password with which we connect to
our database that user should only be
given permissions for DML queries which
means data manipulation queries. data
manipulation queries as in insert
queries, update queries, delete queries.
These statements which are called DDL
queries which is data definition
language which can alter or delete
actual tables from our database. Of
course, when we run this, this will
return a successful response which is an
empty set of rows. But this part will
never run which means our users table is
not going to get deleted. And the reason
as you can see the query one returns
okay but our users table even if you do
a refresh it's still there and the data
is still present and the reason it did
not run was because we pasted this
inside our DB explorer which is table
plus and it was not from an actual
program table plus whatever driver since
it's proprietary we do not know exactly
what database driver they use for
postris but most of the modern drivers
they have all these safety mechanisms so
that they by default block these
backtoback SQL statements. So only the
first one runs. This one gets disabled
because SQL injection has been a classic
vulnerability since decades. A lot of
tools, a lot of drivers and database
ecosystem tools. They have a lot of
safety mechanisms to disable behaviors
like that. But if you're using some
older version of a database driver or a
database driver which does not have all
these security mechanisms then this
statement will actually work and your
users table will get deleted. And
judging by this pattern you can already
imagine an attacker with the correct set
of skills and intentions. They can do a
lot more creative attacks lot more
damage to your wagon and your database.
uh they can do things like use union
statements to extract data from other
tables, other sensitive tables like
payment information. They can also use
database specific functions to read
files from your server's file system.
And in some configurations, they can
also execute operating system commands
to the database. So there is a lot of
attack surface here. That's the reason
SQL injection has been one of the most
destructive vulnerability since decades.
Now going back to our initial
explanation of what exactly is an
injection attack mentioned that
injection happens when languages cross
other languages boundaries inside a
ecosystem ecosystem of browsers,
servers, databases and other tools. Now
looking at our SQL query, if we apply
that theory here, SQL or SQL, it is a
language where certain characters have
special meaning. The single quote here
we use to represent a string. Whatever
comes inside a single quote, a pair of
single quote, that is treated as a
string. The semicolon here that is used
to separate two different statements. If
a semicolon comes inside an SQL
statement, that means that statement is
over and the next statement starts
executing. The double dash here, this
means whatever comes after that will be
treated as a comment and SQL will not be
executing whatever command is there
after the double dash. Same way keywords
like or, drop, where, all these things
they have a specific meaning. And when
we concatenate our SQL string or SQL
template with whatever coming directly
from user input there what we're saying
that we are trusting that the input does
not contain any of these special
characters which is of course asking for
a lot and it is an impossible situation.
Even if the user input is not malicious,
we cannot guarantee that a benign user,
a user who is clueless, they will not
type all these special characters inside
the input box. We are just assuming that
it's all data. And that is the essence
of all injection attacks. This part that
we treated as data and this part which
was supposed to be code but due to the
overlapping meanings of special
characters this thing also became a part
of our code which was supposed to be our
data. So in a way if you want to explain
the meaning of injection attacks it all
boils down to this confusion between
code or data treating data is code or
code as data that's where a lot of
injection based attacks are born from.
So how do we actually fix this? The
answer to that is parameterized queries
and they're also called prepared
statements. And this is how they look.
If we take this statement and copy it
here, instead of doing this string
concatenation where we are taking two
single quotes and we are just pushing
whatever comes from the user inside this
pair of single quotes, instead of doing
this, what if we remove this whole thing
and we wrote something like dollar one
and while we are executing this whole
thing, what we do usually, so let's say
we store this whole thing inside a
variable on statement equals to this
whole thing and we also add a pair of
quotes here whether single quote or
double quote that's on you and your
language and while executing what we do
we have a DB instance or a pool instance
whatever do we have let's call it
something like DB and we call an execute
method whatever your uh database driver
offers or a query method a debuted query
a pass the statement in the first
parameter. In the second parameter, we
pass the slots. Whatever slots that are
supposed to go inside this query. I'll
explain that in a bit. Let's say here we
pass the user input. Okay. Now, let's
make this a little bit bigger. Let me
change the color of this and also the
color of this so that we can
differentiate what is the actual query
and what is the code. Let me write.
Okay. Now the whole idea of
parameterized query is to separate the
query from the user data. The user data
in the sense whatever data that we are
receiving dynamically during runtime
during the execution of our program the
data that we do not have the knowledge
of while we are writing the code or
while our code is compiling. So instead
of building one string with everything
mashed together, we send two things to
our database. Here if you take a look
this is our DB instance pool instance
whatever you want to call it. This part
will differ from language to language
from FMA to framework. So this part we
will ignore the syntax we'll ignore.
Let's focus on this part. This practice
is usually common between all kinds of
drivers and all kinds of ORMS. So you'll
be able to relate this statement. Okay.
Now focusing on our actual query
template or our actual query statement.
the first part from starting from here
to here. Previously where we were
concatenating this part with the user
input what we did we wrote our first
part as it is as it was before select
star from users where email equals to
dash. Okay this part contains no user
data. This usually contains the tables
that we are selecting from whatever
conditions that we are checking and
whatever operations that we are
performing things like update etc. And
in this case this is a select statement.
no user data whatsoever. The second part
comes where we have a slot or the actual
values or the place the slot or the
empty box where the user data will go
eventually and we call these parameters
because parameters in the programming
language jargon means a slot where
eventually data will be pushed in.
Eventually data will be filled in. Now
that we have our statement ready, we
have a slot reserved here. When we
actually execute this statement, we pass
these two things to our database. The
first part, we pass this whole
statement. The statement that our
database is supposed to execute. In the
second parameter, we pass the actual
value. So this user input, this might be
coming from a query parameter from our
HTTP endpoint. Now we take that and we
directly inject it here. And this in
turn will be injected in this parameter.
this query parameter or this empty slot
and if we take this statement let's
paste somewhere here with the color this
so eventually this statement becomes
this thing whatever data whatever user
data whatever data that we pass into a
parameter now this in turn becomes this
which is let's say the user typed alice
atgmail.com
right this is what the query becomes in
At the end, the database takes this
part, this statement, and it knows that
since it encountered a phrase where
there is a dollar sign in front of the
phrase, it is treating this part as a
slot. And what it did, it took the
second argument that we passed into the
query function. It took that and it
injected that into this into this slot.
Now if you ask what is the difference
between this method and the previous
method where we were concatenating
string which was more intuitive and
which was more easy in fact the
difference is when the database
construct this query by taking our
statement and all the arguments this
part whatever it inserts into this slot
this is purely treated as data. There is
no confusion between data and code which
is usually the source of all kinds of
injection attacks. Now that possibility
is gone because if we take the initial
malicious statement this whole thing
let's say we take this whole thing. So
now let's take our malicious example for
our user input. Let's say the attacker
came and passed this whole thing which
is supposed to be a malicious input and
we took that particular user input and
this time we are using parameterized
queries instead of doing string
concatenation. We took that input and we
passed our database the query template
which is this part and the user input
which is this part and our database in
turn constructs this whole statement.
Now what is the difference? Unlike
before when the database encounters this
single code it does not try to confuse
between code and data it does not treat
it as a actual single quote which is
going to merge with the existing single
code and it will complete one part of
the statement. That will not happen.
This will not be a complete statement
because whatever comes inside the slot
it is treated purely as data or in
simple language it is treated purely as
a string. No part of this data will be
confused as a command. And that is why
this whole thing is now just a garbage
string. Since this is clearly not an
email, this will not return any kind of
row from our database. And also since we
are using parent queries, it will not be
able to harm our database in any way
possible. Of course, you can argue that
this particular string this should not
have reached up to this point where we
are executing a statement for an email
with this particular structure. Usually
in our validation layer, we should catch
these kind of strings which means if a
string does not have a structure of an
email then the validation layer should
throw an error saying that this does not
look like an email. This just a random
garbage string. So it will not reach up
to this point. But even if for some
reason your validation layer is weak or
is not as strict, if it did reach up to
this point, then the our database driver
will take care of that. Nowadays, every
single database driver in every language
supports these parameterized queries. In
fact, every OM also uses them by
default. The only way to be vulnerable
is to deliberately if you intentionally
bypass all this safety by building raw
strings by yourself which does not even
make sense or is convenient in any way
possible. That is only when you'll be
subjected to all these different kinds
of attacks and vulnerabilities. So that
is your advice for the first kind of
injection attacks which is SQL
injection. Always use parameterized
queries. Even though this has become
such a common practice that I did not
have to cover this anyway most people
use OMS and OMS by default use
parameterized queries and even if you
use SQL raw strings the database drivers
also encourage you and make it as easy
as possible to use parameterized
queries. This has become such a common
vulnerability that this did not need
covering. But still if you wanted to
understand why this particular type of
injection attack has been so destructive
for so many decades then this part would
be helpful to you to understand what
exactly your database driver does by
using these parameterized queries. Now
some of you might be thinking I use
MongoDB or any other kind of NoSQL or
document database and since I don't
write SQL I am safe and I don't have to
worry about user inputs which is
obviously again not true in MongoDB also
queries are represented as JSON like
objects and when you want to find a user
by email in a similar situation like
this you create an object with an email
field and the value that you're
searching for. And the problem is that
MongoDB query objects can also contain
operators. Things like not equal
operator, the greater than operator, the
exist operator, and many other kinds of
operators. And these operators are
specified as nested objects with special
keys starting with the dollar. So a
normal query might say find where email
equals to this string value. But if the
attacker can control not just the value
but the structure also they can pass an
object with the not equal operator. So
if your application takes a JSON input
from the user and passes it directly to
the database query even though that is
an obviously stupid thing to do and no
one in their same mind will do it but
still if you were to do it an attacker
can inject these operators. So that's
also something you have to be wary of.
Even if you use NoSQL as your database.
Of course, if you use MongoDB or NoSQL
database in the first place, then you
have bigger concerns than worrying about
security. On the same note, there is a
different type of attack, a different
type of injection attack which is called
command injection attack which works
pretty much the same as an SQL
injection. But the attack target is
instead of your database systems or your
backend system, it is your operating
system. In an SQL injection attack, what
happens? You have an SQL query template
and you take user input without proper
caution and without proper techniques.
You just add or concatenate the user
input with your SQL query and pass that
as code instead of treating it as data.
The same kind of thing happens in
command injection where instead of an
SQL string you have a operating system
command can be a system command or it
can be some CLI program that you call
for an example let's say you have a web
service have a web app where you ask
users to upload images and that image in
turn goes to your web server where you
have to process that image process ing
can be of any type. Let's say you can
let's say the request may be to compress
that image or maybe the request is to
resize the image. It can be of any type
depending on what you're providing. So
your web server takes that image but in
order to resize that image or compress
that image etc. What do you do? You use
a CLI application or a CLI tool.
Something like FFmp is a very popular
tool for any kind of image or video
processing. So what you do in your
backend code after you get the user's
file in your handler you execute a OS
function which in turn calls this CLI
tool which is fmmppg and there are some
arguments here something like what is
the height what is the etc etc whatever
arguments usually fmmppg takes and in
the end there is a slot or there is an
option to specify the output image file
name something like output dot jpg. Now
for this what you're doing you are
taking users input for the name of the
output file. So the user has the
capability to define what is going to be
the name of the output file or the input
image. So what you do you just take the
user's input and pass it into your whole
command. So which in turn becomes the
above command which is fine as long as
it is a genuine input. But let's say you
are invoking the same command mpg height
120 width
220 something like this and in the end
you're let's say hyphen o and you
specify the file name here what you're
doing you're passing the user's input as
it is and in this case if the user
inputs something like this semicolon rm
- rf/ this whole thing becomes the
command now so this thing executes But
when it encounters a semicolon, this is
a complete command. And starting from
this, this is going to be executed. And
of course, we all know the destructive
effects of RMRF/
which is deleting your whole root
folder. The attackers can also get
creative. They might use pipes to
redirect the output to a different or
more destructive command. They might
also use amperands to run commands in
the background which might work as a
spyware in your system in your server
system because each shell whether you
are using ZSH or fish or bash whatever
shell that you use each shell has its
own set of special characters and escape
sequences and someone who has the skill
they can do proper research and come up
with more creative exploits for your
system. And the fix for this is similar
to the SQL injection fix which is just
separate the command from its arguments.
Most of these languages the system
languages or languages that enable you
to interact with your operating system
whether it is NodeJS or Go or Python
whatever language that you're using.
They all have these functions that take
the command this part as one parameter
and the arguments in this case the
output file name that in a different
parameter and these functions these
functions that are provided by your
programming languages or your framework
they pass these arguments the arguments
that are coming from the user directly
to the process without them going
through your shell interpreter when the
user's input is passed directly to the
shell interpreter that is treated as
code. As we have already mentioned, all
these injection attacks happen when our
workflow, our system confuses data with
code or code with data. So in order to
prevent that situation, when we use
proper functions provided by our
programming languages, these command
injections can be avoided because these
functions they inject whatever users
data directly into the process when the
program is already running. Instead of
interpreting the programmatic meaning of
the user's input, they treat it directly
as string. So that was a different type
of injection attack which is called
command injection. Now let's try to
summarize the injection attacks. This is
the mental model that applies to pretty
much all the injection attacks. Whenever
you are passing user input, whatever
coming from your user that they type in
their keyboard or paste it, whatever
user input that you are getting in your
server, which is another system, the
system where the user types is the
browser and that travels to your system,
which is the operating system of the
server or your backend system, whatever
programming language or framework that
you're using. When that happens, whether
that is SQL or NoSQL or shell commands,
HTML, LDAP, XML or anything else,
whatever you can imagine, you have to
ensure that the user input is purely as
data. It should never be treated as
something that can be executed,
something that can be interpreted. And
the safest way to do that is to use
APIs, use functions, use methodologies
that enable you to separate structure
from the data, separate code from the
data, which in our case when we talked
about SQL injection, they are
parameterized queries. And in case of
command injection, they are argument
arrays which are provided by your
programming languages or your
frameworks. Something that you should
never do is doing all these kinds of
dangerous or sensitive operations using
string concatenations or using template
strings by mixing user input with the
control syntax. So the thing to be
paranoid of that I mentioned in the
first part of this video is whenever
you're building a string that will be
interpreted by another system and that
string also includes any kind of user
input you have to stop and think more
about it and always try to find a
parameterized alternative to that and
most of the time it almost always
exists. Next let's talk about
authentication. We have already covered
authentication and authorization and a
lot of aspects of that in the
authentication authorization video. But
in this part in this section of this
video we are going to look at
authentication and authorization by
keeping vulnerabilities in our mind by
thinking about where the weaknesses
might be where people usually mess up.
So to give a brief authentication is
basically the process of verifying the
identity of your user to finding out
which row exactly in your database in
the users table associates with this
user who is trying to currently access
your system. That is basically the
question that we are trying to answer.
Every time we are talking about
authentication, if you get
authentication wrong, the malicious user
or the attacker, they can impersonate
your users. They can access their
private data. They can take actions on
their behalf and they can also steal
their money. If you are dealing with any
kind of payment related operations and
these kinds of vulnerabilities, the
account takeover kind of vulnerabilities
we see every day in real world. So there
are a couple of obvious thumb rules that
we can follow where typical
vulnerabilities arise so that we can
avoid as back end engineers these kinds
of issues in our systems. But before we
dive into the technical details, I have
an advice. uh since we are talking about
authentication and authorization if you
can avoid implementing authentication
yourself and here I'm not talking about
avoiding implementing your own
cryptography algorithms etc. I mean in
the general sense if you can avoid
implementing the whole authentication
flow at least in your production systems
then you should definitely go for it. If
you have the budget, if you have the
approval of your company for the budget
of taking an authentication and
authorization provider, then that is
always a good move because the obvious
benefits even if you think beyond
security. The first thing it saves you a
lot of time. Of course, when your
service finally scales to thousands of
users or millions of users, you are
going to see your authentication
provider sending you invoice bills of
thousands of dollars. But by the time
you reach millions of users, you most
probably have a revenue source. So you
can anyway handle the ollated bills. But
as I was saying, the first benefit of
taking an O provider is the amount of
time saved and in the amount of money
that you can save on your developer
salary. Because to get the whole
authentication and authorization flow,
right? And when I say the whole
authentication and authorization flow, I
don't mean a very simple JWT verify and
storing the token in your cookie and
verifying it. That simple flow is
obviously something that you can
implement. There are LLMs that can
definitely implement them for you and
there is not a lot of difficulties or
weaknesses when it comes to security in
that flow. But when we are talking about
production systems, it is much more
complicated than that and the scope is
not as clear as that. Most of the time
when we are talking about the whole
authentication and authorization flow in
production systems we generally prefer
stateful authentications by stateful
authentication I mean we can keep track
of all the devices where the user has
currently logged in and if the user
wants they can immediately revoke the
sessions of all these devices at once or
if we want we as the provider of the
service as the provider of the system he
can revoke all the sessions of the user
from all the devices and log them out.
We have the capability for that. So that
kind of capability, that kind of setup
is called a stateful authentication. If
you want to learn more about stateful
authentications, stateless
authentication, you can revisit the
authentication and authorization video.
But if we want to provide a stateful
authentication workflow to our users,
the things start getting more
complicated because the setup is not as
straightforward as signing a JWT,
sending the JWT and the front end
storing it in cookie and your server
verifying it with each request. When we
talk about stateful authentication,
there is databases involved. There are
caches involved like radius. Then you
have to think about what is the best
place to store users permission. Then
you have to think about timeouts. Then
as I talked about you also have to think
about all these revoking mechanisms.
Revoking from your cache, revoking from
your database, right? That is just one
part of the equation which is stateful
authentication. Then comes the social
authentication like sign in with Google
that we see in pretty much all the
professional SAS services or your
service consers. Then sign in with
GitHub. Mostly all these services, SAS
services, a production SAS service. It
generally provides two three social
providers something like Google or sign
in with GitHub, sign in with Twitter
whatever. So for that you have to
implement oath flows yourself oathflow
not just in your back end also in your
front end with the redirect mechanism
for a very good and very smooth user
experience. Once that is out of
question, now you have to also implement
the system so that your email and
password based authentication which when
we are talking about stateful
authentication which is directly
concerned with this this is directly
connected to your social provider
authentication which is your oathflow
which means let's say I sign in to your
service with my email which is 1mail.com
some sample email and my password
something like password. It's ironic
since we are talking about security in
this video but anyway for the sake of
this example let's say your password is
password. Now you as a user sign up to
my service using this credential and you
frequently sign into the service using
these credentials. So one day what you
do you sign in instead of your
credentials which is email and password
you try to sign in with Google with the
sign in with Google button. When that
happens, your oath system should be
capable enough that it can connect your
email credential flow with your oath
flow which is sign in with Google flow
so that it does not treat this user even
though they have the same email as a
different user just because they used a
different method of sign in. Right? That
is another problem. And I can go on and
on about a lot of not problems but
inconveniences. Inconveniences which
your developers are going to spend weeks
on or you are going to spend weeks on if
you are a solo developer or you are
building your own project. Of course you
can go ahead and cut corners in a lot of
these things that is anyway going to
compromise with your security or b with
your user experience. You have to make a
trade-off on either of these. every time
you cut corners. So with all these
things, the argument always comes down
to this. Use a O provider. They take
care of all these things. The modern
providers like clerk, they also provide
arbback permissions, a lot of other
stuff like advanced security stuff they
take care of. Of course, these services
they might also have user experience
issues. They might also have
vulnerabilities in future. But they are
a security company. Their whole service
is surrounded around authentication and
security. So they have a dedicated
security team which thinks about
security 24/7. They handle edge cases
that you will not think of and they will
respond to new kinds of attacks that
come in the market very quickly since
they are spending 24/7 on finding out
and fixing different different bugs or
vulnerabilities and all these things
that I talked about the different
inconveniences that you have to face as
a developer they have already fixed this
and with just a few buttons and with an
API key you can provide worldclass user
experience to your users for
authentication. and also worldcl class
security. So in my opinion, it's always
worth it to make that tradeoff of paying
a few bucks for an o provider instead of
going ahead and implementing your own o
flow and dealing with all these things.
Of course, let's say when you have
thousands or millions of users and your
authentication provider bill is
crossing, let's say $10,000 or $20,000
bill, then you can definitely consider
migrating to your own authentication
setup. By then, you'll have the revenue,
you'll have your developer bandwidth and
priority state. So, then you can
definitely go ahead and implement your
own o workflow, which definitely makes
sense. But when you are starting out, it
is always recommended to go with an O
provider. But even if you do listen to
this advice and you get an O provider,
you still need to understand how
authentication works. You need to know
about configure, what can go wrong and
how to integrate it securely. That is
the reason we'll talk about
authentication, different different
issues in authentication right now.
Starting with the first kind under
authentication is the password storage.
So since we are talking about
authentication, let's start with
passwords. Since most of you will deal
with passwords even if you are using an
oservice. So during the time of sign up,
a user comes and they enter an email and
a password. They hit enter and that goes
to your server. Now the question is what
do you do with it on the back end? Of
course when we talking about server we
mean the back end and you as a back end
engineer. What exactly do you do with
it? How do you store it so that you can
verify it later when they log? And for
some of the advanced users, this might
sound very silly and a very beginner
developer targeted, but we have to talk
about this so that we can understand the
reasoning behind the advanced password
storage practices that we have today
which are very common in the developer
ecosystem. But as a beginner, you might
not be aware of those. So the knive
approach of storing password is of
course having a database column with
text type and you just store whatever
the user has sent you in the plain text
format right so let's say the user has
something like 1 2 3 4 5 you take that
this is your server and you store it in
your database right so that the next
time user wants to sign in he passes the
email and 1 2 3 4 5 you which gets to
your server the server fetch matches the
user's password using the email from the
database which is 1 2 3 4 5 m matches
and the server lets the user login right
as simple as it can get. But the problem
with that is databases get breached
every single day. If you follow the tech
news or cyber security news, every other
day you'll see a headline saying that
this company's this database got
breached and a lot of users credentials
uh got leaked. And it happens to
companies of all sizes, not just big
companies and not just small companies.
Every kind of company has the same kind
of probability to go through a breach.
And breaches happen for a lot of
reasons. It it can be because of some
insider employee trying to take revenge
on you or it may be because you are
using a third party service and they got
breached and in turn your database got
breached. There can be a lot of reasons
but the truth is they do happen and when
your database gets breached and you are
storing your password in plain text
format all those passwords are leaked.
At that point you can argue that okay
the moment you know you have a breach
you go ahead and uh reset all the
credentials of all the users log them
out and ask them to create a new
password. But the problem is the moment
a user's password is breached their
presence in any kind of internet website
is also the reason being more than 70%
of the users they use their same
passwords in multiple sites right they
use the same kind of email and password
combination in pretty much all the
sites. A very less number of users use
password managers which randomizes the
password for each site. But still a lot
of internet traffic, a lot of internet
users where you use the password. So the
moment your database gets breached and
you expose a certain user's email and
password combination, the attacker can
pick that up and they can run that on a
lot of sites. can be payment related
sites, it can be e-commerce sites, it
can be social media sites, a lot of
sites and there is a huge probability
they will be able to match one of those
sites and they will be able to take over
that user's account. Usually users are
not aware when database breaches happen
unless they follow tech news very
closely. So that is a huge security risk
storing passwords in plain text in your
databases. Even if there is no breach
happening when you're storing passwords
in plain text format that means that
your developers the developers who are
working on your system the developers
who are building the back end they can
see those passwords and your database
administrators they can see those
passwords anyone with the database
access in your system they can see any
user's password in your system so you're
basically trusting every employee every
contractor freelancer everyone who might
access your systems with all your users
credentials and their online presence.
So by now we know that storing passwords
plain text in our database is a wrong
way to do it. So what is the solution?
That's why people have come up with
hashing. Now of course hashing was not
necessarily invented for storing
passwords in databases but hashing is a
very good use case for password storage.
Uh if you are from a computer science
background, you will already be aware of
this. Hash is typically a function which
is called the hashing function which is
one way that is the most important tool
of any kind of hashing function. And the
goal of this hashing function is it can
take any kind of string 1 2 3 A B C at
the rate any kind of strings as an input
of any length also. The strings can be
of any length starting from length of
one to length of hundreds of characters.
They can take any kind of input of any
kind of length but in the output the
condition is they always have to return
a string or any kind of output of fixed
length. Depending on what kind of hash
that you use the length will differ but
the condition is it always has to be
fixed length. If the hashing function
says that it will return the output of
27 characters, then the goal is it does
not matter what is the length of our
input. The output will always be of 27
characters. And the second condition is
for the same input does not matter how
many times we call the hashing function.
It always has to return the same output
of the same length. Right? It cannot be
a random function which gives us
different output for the same input
every time we call it. The output will
always have to be same and the output
will always have to be of fixed number
of characters which summarizes what is a
hashing function. And the last condition
was it is always one way which means we
can get the same output for the same
input of the fixed number of characters.
It does not matter how many times we run
the hashing function but we should not
be able to get the input from the output
right it should be mathematically
impossible to get the input from the
output using the computing capability
that we have at the moment given all
these features of a hashing function
this is a very good candidate for us to
store our password in a database so what
we do let's say the password is 1 2 3 4
5 instead of storing this particular a
string in our database. We take the hash
of it. Let's write now let's say h
password hasher the input is 1 2 3 4 5
there is a cost factor which we'll
ignore and we say generate hash gives us
a set of characters let's say paste it
here. Okay. So instead of storing 1 2 3
5 we pass it to a hashing function. In
this case we pass it through bcrypt
which is a very popular hashing library.
and we store this hash in our database.
So the next time the user logs into our
database, what happens? We fetch the
hash of the password for that user which
we have stored in the users table or the
accounts table or wherever. We fetch the
stored password, the hashed password of
the user. Then what we do, we take the
user's input for the sign-in attempt. We
take that password and we hash it and we
try to match whether the current hashed
password matches our store hashed. If it
does then the user has typed the right
password and we let them we let the sign
in successfully. Now in this case think
about the situation of our database
getting breached. What happens? The
attacker gets access to all the password
hashes of all our users. the hashes of
the passwords, not the actual password.
And since one of the properties of the
hashing function is you cannot under no
circumstance with the computing power of
our current systems get the input from
the output of a hash. The user's
identity is safe in the internet. The
password is never exposed. The attacker
under no circumstance can get the access
to the actual password. Now that we have
discovered hashing, the use of hashing
to store our password securely in our
database, we should be secure safe,
right? Unfortunately, that is not the
case. Since hashing has become the
industry standard for storing passwords
in databases, of course, attackers also
know this fact. And what they have done
is they have built a huge storage of
preomputed hashes. Let's say there is a
big table which can be used in scripts
like Python or any other exploiting
scripts. And this table is basically a
one to1 map. For example, for the string
something like 1 2 3 4 5 which is a
common password that people use in a lot
of sites. For that they will have a hash
something like dollar like mapped to
this. Same way for the string password
they'll have some other hash. If you do
a simple Google search, you can find an
image like this. So where you can see
there are common passwords on the left
side and hashes of those on the right.
So train table is basically a table with
common passwords and their hashes. And
of course not every hash returns the
same string the same output string for a
particular input. But since usually
there are industry standards of which
hash is currently the most popular. So
attackers can use that particular hash
to build this particular rainbow table
of common passwords and their hashes.
Now using this what they can do is let's
say your database gets breached but this
time instead of storing your passwords
in plain text you have stored them using
hashes and you are all confident that
you are super safe the attackers can
never get access to your users
credentials but again what happens once
the database is breached and attackers
get access to all those hashed passwords
one of the techniques that they can
apply is taking a rainbow table like
this which has the mapping of all the
common passwords and their hashes. they
can run a lookup and when they do that
there is a huge probability that some
percentage of your users are using
commonly used passwords like password or
1 2 3 4 5 or password at 1 2 3 all these
common passwords and those attackers
they can get a couple of matches where
the hash is exactly the same as one of
the hashes in the rainbow table and
since a hash function will always return
the same output put string with the same
number of characters for a particular
input. They can exactly reverse map what
is the password of the user for that
particular hash and using that they can
find out the passwords of at least some
percentage of your users and that is why
you're still not safe even if you just
use hashing to store your passwords in
your database. So what we can do for
this situation is something called
salting. Now what is salting? So far we
have discussed that for each input of a
commonly used password something like 1
2 3 4 5 will always produce the same
hash like z 7 something of some number
of characters as long as you are using
the same hashing function and since they
always produce the same hash for the
same input they are prone to rainbow
table attacks in order to prevent that
sameness what we have come up with is
salting. Now what does salting mean? It
is a very simple trick/ technique to
avoid this sameness problem of same
input generating the same output which
is universally. Now what we do a user
signs up say with the name a at the
ratemail.com
and the password 1 2 3 4 5. In the first
method what we used to do we used to
store in plain text. Second, we started
using a hashing algorithm. By the way,
for a long time, BCrypt has been the
default hashing algorithm for pretty
much all the web apps on the internet.
But recently, Argon 2 ID has been the
industry standard for the most secure
and most performant hashing algorithm.
That is something that you should know
of and you can do more reading on that
on your own. One of the good resources
for reading about authentication is is
Lucia O. Lucia has been one of the good
authentication libraries with good
primitives and a very well-ritten
documentation but Lucia is no longer a
authentication library. Instead it is
more of a guidance towards implementing
your own authentication using the best
industry practices etc. So it is a very
good resource to understand the
mechanics of secure authentication and
industry standards is something that you
can explore on your own to implement
secure authentication. Now coming back
that is the second method where we
implemented hashing. Now in the third
method what we are saying is just
hashing is not enough. We also have to
integrate salulting here. Now what does
salulting mean? Let's say the user then
signs up with these credentials which is
a zmail.com and 1 2 3 4 5 as password.
Previously, previously what we used to
do, we used to take the password 1 2 3 4
5 and run it through a hashing function
in case of argon 2 ID and that or brypt
and that returned us some kind of hash
of some number of characters. Now in
order to prevent the sameness problem
what we'll do we will add a new element
to this which is a random number. So
instead of just passing the password
string, we'll also add a salt and salt
in this case is just a string which is
randomly generated for that particular
user. Let's say this is the user 14 in
our platform. So for user 14, we have a
database row in our database where we
store the user's name, we store the
user's email, we store the hashed
password. Now we will also store the
user's salt. We'll generate a salt. Now
this salt has to be generated from a
cryptographically sudo random generated
function. You'll easily find all these
different kinds of functions from very
popular libraries. OpenSSL is one of
those. And we have to generate this salt
which will be something like SP3
some string and we'll also store that in
our database. And while hashing what we
do we take the password we concatenate
with the salt is a randomly generated
string that is unique to this particular
user in our platform and then we hash
the whole thing and after that whatever
we get we store that in our hashed
password column. Now in this new
scenario what happens? Let's say our
database gets breached. The attacker
gets access to all the hashed passwords
and the salt and users email everything.
But in order to get access to the user's
actual password, not the hashed
password. Previously they used rainbow
tables which had a mapping of users
common passwords and the hashed version
of it. Now when they run the rainbow
table against this leaked database, they
will find zero results because each of
these hashed passwords have been hashed
with a randomly generated salt. So this
hashed string will never match any other
string in the world. It does not matter
even though the common password is 1 2 3
4 5 and the user's password is 1 2 3 4 5
but the attacker will never get to know
this because this 1 2 3 4 5 which is the
common password and the hashed version
of that which is in the rainbow table of
the attacker and this version which is
the 1 2 3 4 5 is the actual password of
the user in our platform but the hashed
version of that has been hashed using a
salt which we have generated randomly.
So there is no way these two are ever
going to match and that is how we
prevent rainbow table attacks by using
salts and not just a hashing function
for storing our password. Now with the
introduction of hashing with the
introduction of salting we should be
completely safe from any kind of
password based attacks. Unfortunately
that is still not true. Now comes
another threat which is the brute force
attacks. These days especially with the
advent of all these LLMs and all GPUs
have become very popular and there are
companies there are manufacturers there
are providers also cloud providers which
provide GPU instances for some fixed
amount of price. Now modern graphic
cards or GPUs they are very good at
computing hashes. A single GPU can
compute billions of SSHA 256 hashes per
second. Billions. So even with salting
an attacker with your database can do
what's called an offline brute forcing
for each user. They can take the salt
and they can try common passwords one by
one. They can hash that common password
combined with the salt and they can
check the hashed password with the
breach hash password. And with their
capability of billions of attempts per
second, they can even try every password
up to eight characters, every common
password pattern, every word with common
substitutions within a matter of days.
And in order [clears throat] to prevent
this problem, we do not use common hash
functions like SHA 256 or MD5. These are
also hash functions commonly used for
file-based hashing to match the
integrity of files when we are
transferring files over the internet.
But we do not use them for password
hashing exactly for this reason because
our graphics card computing is so fast
at these hashes that they can do
billions of hashing functions attempts
per second. This is the exact reason we
use slow hashing functions which I have
already mentioned. It's called decrypt
or script or the current industry
standard which is argu ID. These are
called slow hashing functions and they
have been specifically made for password
hashing. The other hashing functions the
MD5 SHA 256 these are general purpose
hashing functions which have a lot of
use cases but these ones the slow
hashing functions which are deliberately
made slower because of the use case of
password hashing they have what we call
as a cost factor cost factor or also
called as work factor which controls how
slow we want them to be depending on our
systems bandwidth depending on our
systems computing capability we can
decide how slow we want these algorithms
to be. So we can decide while we are
hashing our passwords for a new user, we
can decide whether we want this
particular hashing to take 100 millconds
or we want it to take 5 millconds that
is on us depending on how much latency
how much computing power we can afford
in our system. Now if you think about it
for a genuine user who is trying to log
into our platform with their email which
was a at the ratemail.com and 1 2 3 4 5
and we are using argon do id or bcrypt
for hashing this and we have decided
that we want this particular hashing
function to take let's say 400 millconds
right so for a genuine user logging in
through browser the login taking
somewhere around 400 to 600 milliseconds
is not a big deal. In fact, this is
almost imperceptible to the user. But
for the same scenario for an attacker
for a malicious user who is trying to
brute force his way into our system by
taking a breached database and trying
out billions of guesses offline. For
them, this changes the whole equation
because previously when they could try a
billion attempts per second, now it
comes down to just four or five attempts
per second. Which means instead of
cracking being able to crack users
passwords in the matter of days, now it
will take them decades or even
centuries. The next topic to discuss
under authentication is sessions. Your
user has logged in and they have
provided their email address. They have
sent it to your server. You have checked
with hashing and whatever authentication
mechanism that you have and you have
made sure that your user has proven
their identity. Now what is the next
step? We cannot possibly make our users
enter their password every time they
want to access our platform or every
time they want to make a new request.
that would be a very bad user
experience. So for that we need to
remember that they have already
authenticated with our system with our
platform and this is exactly where we
talk about what we call as sessions.
When a user successfully signs in or
successfully logs in the server does
three things. First, it generates a
random session identifier. I 1 2 3 A Z
whatever. This is a very long random
string. Ideally somewhere between 128 to
256 characters and again it must be
generated by a cryptographically secure
pseudo random number generator function
which are provided by popular libraries.
Why do we need to make this random?
Because if an attacker can guess your
session ID, if they can guess this
particular session identifier, they can
potentially hijack any session of any of
your users. And by making sure that our
session identifier, this whole session
ID is somewhere between 128 characters
to 256. Even if it is just 128
characters or 128 bits, we are making
sure that there are more possible
session ids than the number of atoms in
our universe. Which means that guessing
this number is almost practically
impossible. The second thing that our
server does is storing this session
identifier in our database. Now this
could be radius which provides a very
fast setting and accessing time which
can provide a better user experience or
it can be your primary database also
something like posgress or MySQL. With
this session identifier we also store
some kind of metadata in our database
again in radius or our own database.
things like who does this session
belongs to the users information when it
was created so that we can do operations
like timing it out revoking etc when it
will expire or default expiry time 7
days or whatever the IP address of the
user so that in the user's dashboard we
can show from which location this
sign-in attempt was made or which are
all the locations where the user has
signed in and also the user agent the
user agent which is basically a request
header in our API calls. This tells our
server from what kind of device or what
kind of browser we are trying to access
the platform. So using the user agent
our back end our platform can atom can
know that the user is trying to access
from a Chrome browser or a Firefox
browser from an Android phone from an
iPhone whatever the device type or the
browser type is. And the third thing,
the last thing, the server sends this
session identifier, this
cryptographically safe session
identifier to the browser and asks the
browser to store it inside a cookie. Now
since this is stored inside a cookie,
all the subsequent request that is made
to our platform or our back end, this
particular session identifier is always
sent back to us to our platform. And for
each of those requests, the server
extracts the session ID, the 128
character random number or random string
from the cookie. It looks up in the
persistent store whether it is radius or
posgress depending on your
implementation. Finds the associated
user who has initiated this session who
is the user of this session and finally
it knows that this is the particular
user who is currently making the
request. Now even if you are using JWDs
which have a slightly different format a
slightly different workflow because they
are stateless and we don't maintain the
session in our persistent store but the
philosophy of identifying an
authenticated user works pretty much the
same way as a stateful workflow which we
just discussed. Now when you are using
cookies there are some flags there are
some configuration of a cookie that we
should be aware of and that is always
recommended to be used in a production
system. The first one being HTTP
only. This means that when we set HTTP
only flag to true for this cookie which
has our session identifier. This means
that if your site has an XSS
vulnerability, we'll talk about XSS in a
bit, but it basically means that if an
attacker is able to run JavaScript in
your user's browser through your
platform through some vulnerability in
your site, then your site or your
platform is said to have an XSS
vulnerability. If [clears throat] you do
have that, then some potential
JavaScript can read your local storage.
So storing your session identifier or
storing your JWT tokens in your local
storage is always discouraged. That is
why setting HTTP only to a cookie. Make
sure that this malicious JavaScript
snippet it does not have access to this
particular cookie. Of course, JavaScript
can also read cookies only if HTTP only
is not set to true. And that is why it
is important if you're storing any kind
of sensitive information related to
authentication. This is usually a
session identifier in case of stateful
authentication or AJ token in case of
stateless authentication. It is
important that you make this flag only
to true so that JavaScript cannot access
your session ID or your JWT token. The
second flag is secure. Then this flag is
set to true. Your browser makes sure
that this cookie is only transferred
back to your [clears throat] platform,
back to your back end only if the
connection is HTTPS.
It will not try to send the cookie over
HTTP or HTTP protocol. if TLS or SSL is
not enabled for that connection. Now it
is important because HTTP traffic can be
intercepted on public networks on public
Wi-Fi or cafes by malicious ISPs or if
the Wi-Fi router itself has some kind of
spyware configured which can read all
the traffic flowing through that
endpoint flowing through that hop. So if
your sensitive cookie which has the
session identifier or the JWT token, it
gets sent over an HTTP connection can be
stolen by anyone who has access to that
endpoint who has set up that spyware or
someone who is observing the traffic
with a tool like Wireshark. So the
secure flag make sure that your cookie
is only transferred over HTTPS
connections which are by default
encrypted. Even if someone is watching
your traffic, they cannot make sense of
it because everything is encrypted.
Third important flag is same site. This
flag controls whether this particular
key can be sent during cross origin
requests. Now we'll talk about what is
cross origin. But this can have three
kind of values. One is strict, second is
lax and third is none. Okay. What does
strict mean? It is exactly what it
sounds like. The cookie where we have
stored our session identifier or our JWT
token. It will only get sent to the
domain or the platform or the site where
the request is originating from which is
essentially our own back end. So for
example, if someone clicks on a link
which is a link to your site but it is
hosted on some other site. In that case
the cookie will not be sent because this
is essentially not your originating
request. It will only get sent if it is
a request is starting from your own
front end from your own site. with the
same site flag set to lax. What happens?
The cookie will be sent for top level
requests which means a direct link for
your site but it will not get triggered
for other types of elements like images
or iframes. We'll cover why we are
talking about images or iframes when we
are talking about links and duplicates
in a attack class which is called CSR
which is called cross-sight request
forgery which involves making use of
images and iframes to trick our server
into believing that the request is a
genuine request originating from our
platform or our site or our front end.
So with the same site configured to
lags, we are only allowing top level
links and not any kind of triggers
started from images or iframes. When it
is set to none, it is the most relaxed.
It is sent for all kinds of request. But
it requires that the secure flag has to
be at least set to for some kind of
security. So in our case for storing a
session ID cookie you either want strict
that is the best case scenario or you
never want to make it as none. This
prevents this whole class of attack
which is called CSRF or site request
forgery which we'll cover in a later
part of this video. Now with that
talking about cookies we have covered
talking about stateful authentication
and the kind of vulnerabilities and the
security mechanisms that you have to
keep in mind when you are dealing with
stateful authentications.
[clears throat] Now coming to stateless
authentication where we are primarily
dealing with JWT. There is an
alternative to stateful authentication
or stateful sessions or serverside
sessions which are called JWTs. Now the
difference is with sessions what happens
your server your database it stores the
session data the users information the
IP address the user agent whatever
information that particular session has
it stores it in the database and it
gives the client just the ID of the
session. This is just one column of that
session row and the client stores that
ID and in every subsequent request our
server our database is able to take out
that particular session row by using
this ID is the session ID. The
difference in JWT is the whole session
data. This as you can see the decoded
payload that is shown here in the
official JWT site. This is called
JWT.io. Here the actual session data is
sent to the user or sent to the front
end sent to the browser. So that for
every subsequent request the user the
client is going to tell us who the user
is. One natural question that comes to
mind in this case is if the user is
going to tell us if the front end or
browser is going to tell us who the user
is, isn't it prone to all kinds of
attacks like the access is within the
user's hand? Now if they want they can
imperson it as any other user in the
platform and tell us that I am not user
A and I am user B. So I should have
access to user V's account and a lot of
different kinds of attacks like that.
Fortunately that does not happen because
of how JWTs itself are constructed and
all the different pieces that come
together to make a JWT based
authentication workflow possible. Now if
we take a look at this particular JWT
example which is shown here, it has
three parts. The header which is the
first part which is shown in green. The
payload the middle part or the second
part which is shown in white and the
last part which is also called the
signature is shown in purple here. Now
the header it describes the token. It
describes what kind of algorithm was
used for this particular JWT. The
payload contains what we call as claims
in the JWT jargon. It is basically some
pieces of information that we manually
store inside the JWT for all the back
and forth transferring that happens
between the client and the server. Now
if you take a look inside the claims
table, we have a couple of common
fields. One is the sub field as per the
JWT standard. This is the subject of the
JWT and in other words the actual user
which can be the ID of the user as per
the platform as per our platform. It can
be UU ID or any kind of ID that you
generate for your platform for your
database. It also includes another field
called IAT which is the actual timestamp
when the JWT was created. And using this
particular field, our server logic, our
server code can decide whether it is
timed this JWT is expired or not
depending on when it was issued and for
how long we are letting JWTs to work.
Apart from these ones, the default ones,
you can also add your own claims. Claims
are just a fancy way of saying key value
pairs, pieces of information that you
can store inside AJW. So apart from the
default ones, you can also store your
own custom claims. In this case, the
name of the user is stored and also the
information that whether this particular
user is an admin or not that is also
stored as a custom claim. Now the last
part which is in the purple here inside
the JWT token. The last part we call as
JWT signature which involves three
parts. One is the header. Second, the
payload and taking these two and signing
them with a secret token. Again,
[clears throat] a randomly generated
cryptographically secure string and we
sign these two header and payload
together. And whatever we get that is
the signature of this the last part.
This is how it typically works in case
of JWT based workflow which is the
stateless workflow. user comes and
provides their email and their password,
sends it to our server. Our server
verifies it and if the password is
successful and everything. Now in this
flow also we use the same kind of
password storage and password
interaction mechanism which is hashing
the password salting the password and
everything that does not change. What
changes is the actual session storing
and session not storing part. So here
after the password matching and
everything is successful the server
creates a JWT which looks something like
this with the user's ID and other
relevant information like if if they
want to store the user's name the admin
and the issued at field is automatically
created by whatever library that we are
using for interacting with JWTs then the
server signs the payload using a string
a random string which is stored inside
the environment variable of the server
using that string it signs the payload
and whatever JWT is generated after the
signing this JWT is sent to the client
for storing and for sending this back to
the server for every subsequent request.
Now client take this stores it ideally
in memory or in local storage in some
cases or in cookies and for every other
subsequent request the client sends this
back in an authorization header. Now
server gets the request. It tries to
extract this particular JWT from the
authorization header. It verifies the
signature. Usually libraries provide a
function called verify which takes
secret key which is stored again inside
our environment variable and it tells us
whether this JWT is successfully
verified or not. If the signature is
valid then the verify function will
return true and the server will know
that this payload has not been modified
or has not been subjected to any kind of
tampering. So the whatever information
inside this is completely true. Now
looking at this whole flow, one big
advantage is the server does not need to
store anything inside the database as
compared to the previous stateful
workflow where we had to store the
session information either in radius or
our database. In this case, everything
happens on the fly during runtime by
checking just the JWT claims. And
because of this region using JWTs
scaling is a lot easier because there is
no overhead of interacting with our
database or caching layer using radius.
But even with JWTs there are of course
some of the less favorable properties of
JWTs that we have to talk about since we
are talking about security. The first
one which is the very obvious and very
important one is revocation is hard.
Now, if you think back, if you look back
at our sessions example, with sessions,
if you wanted to log a user out, what
you had to do was simply go into your
database and delete that particular
session from the database immediate and
the next time the user refreshes or
sends any kind of request, the front-end
platform should ideally log the user
out. But if we talk about JWTs, this
functionality, this revoking
functionality, at least the immediate
revoking functionality does not work as
smoothly. You cannot just delete a token
from the client. Since JWTs are created
and sent to the client for storing it
and sending it back to us for every
subsequent request, we cannot just ask
the client to delete the token from the
browser. And in turn as a result of this
one primary security vulnerability that
arises here is if the user's account is
compromised if somehow some other
malicious user got access to the user's
account and the user sends us as a
platform a support query that their
account has been compromised and they
want us to revoke all their logged in
sessions [snorts] from all devices. Now
we are in a difficult spot since we have
implemented stateless authentication. We
cannot help the user in any way because
we don't have the capability to revoke
any kind of sessions from any devices.
We had implemented stateful
authentication then we could help the
user by logging out of all the devices
in a moment's notice. Of course over the
time after realizing the limitations of
JWTs the community has come up with some
workarounds. One of the popular ones is
blacklisted tokens which means that for
that particular user we take that
particular user the next time the
request comes and we add it as a
blacklist to our uh database or to our
caching layer with radius and we call
that a blacklisted token which means we
will not serve successful responses for
any requests that has this particular
token attached to it. The second one,
the second workaround is using short
expiration expiration time with refresh
tokens. Now this is a very popular
workflow. What happens with this is
instead of issuing just one token to the
user after a successful login what we do
after a successful login we issue two
kinds of token. One is access token and
the second one is a refresh token. Now
the general practice is keeping the
expiry of access token to something very
short 5 minutes or 10 minutes and the
expiry of refresh token to something
longer let's say 1 day or 7 days
depending on how paranoid you are how
secure you want your systems to be and
for every subsequent request the user
will attach the access token but once
the 5 minute window is gone once the
access token is expired hired.
Technically what happens the server will
obviously throw 401 unauthorized
response code back to the client and in
the client when it sees that our server
has responded with 401. What it will do?
It will use the refresh token and the
refresh token is supposed to be saved by
the client upon successful login
completion which it will receive from
the server. The client will save this
refresh token somewhere safe in local
storage. And when the access token is
expired, the client will send the
refresh token back to the server saying
that uh the access token is expired. I
need a new access token. The server will
check the validity of this refresh token
and it will check whether the refresh
token is expired or not. If it is not,
then it will again issue two sets of
token again a new access token and a new
refresh token and the cycle continues.
After that what happens with this flow
is even if the account gets compromised
in some way and the attacker is able to
get a hold of the access token then the
session will only last for 5 minutes
after that they cannot refresh the token
since they do not have access to the
refresh token. Even if they do have
access to the refresh token again that
will also expire in one day. So these
are not perfect workarounds but these
are the workarounds that the community
and the engineering standards have come
up with to mitigate the revocation
challenge of JWTs. And another confusion
that usually happens is this particular
string which is the payload part of the
JWT. This is just a B 64 encoded string.
So if we take this and let's paste 64 we
paste here and we say decode then we can
see the full JSON here ID of the user
the name whether the user is admin or
not when was this issued etc. Of course
we cannot really go ahead and make any
change here. Let's try to do that. Let's
say instead of John do we remove the E
part. So now it's just John do and we
take this and we let's say we want to
encode this. We paste this new JSON and
we encode it in the new B 64 and let's
paste let's copy this new B 64 string.
Go back to RGWT and let's try to change
it here. Now the moment you try to
change the payload in the signature part
which is in turn the verification part
it says that the signature verification
has failed which means that the server
will immediately know someone has
tampered with the payload and this JWT
should not be trusted and the server
will not allow the request to go
through. But the fact that this string
is just a base 64 encoded string means
means that we should not store any kind
of sensitive information inside this
only store those kinds of information
which when exposed to external users or
malicious users. There is nothing much
they can do with that information. It is
only helpful to our server. And the last
problem and the most discussed problem
with are the storage. Where should you
keep the JWT token when you send it back
to the client? Where is the ideal spot
for the client to keep the JWT token?
Now, local storage is still the most
used solution even though local storage
is vulnerable to a lot of different
kinds of attacks since it is accessible
by any JavaScript snippet if your site
is vulnerable to XSS based attacks. So,
local storage is obviously not a good
choice since XSS can steal it. The
second option is cookies and for cookies
again in order to prevent JavaScript
from accessing that cookie you have to
make it a HTTP only cookie which we just
discussed. Now with all this you are
anyway back to our cookie based solution
the HTTP only cookie based session
solution. So my general advice when it
comes to authentication, when you're
choosing between stateless and stateful
authentication is unless you have
specific scaling requirements like
horizontal scaling, multiple servers
being able to authenticate a particular
user request, unless you are in a
situation like that, always prefer
stateful authentication, always prefer
sessions. And even if you have scaling
requirements, even if you have a
requirement where multiple servers need
to authenticate a particular user
request, you can make use of distributed
key value pair based databases like
radius to store the user sessions. That
is not a problem. So session based
authentication, stateful authentication
is always preferred and always advised
as per my opinion over stateless
authentication. The tradeoffs of
stateless authentication are just not
worth it. Stateful authentication or
session based authentications are even
simpler. The revocation strategies very
straightforward and the whole workflow
and the architecture is compatible with
most kind of SAS projects. But if you do
use JWTs, always use short expiration
times. something from minutes to hours,
not days. And implement refresh token
flows with serverside storage and always
use HTTP only cookies rather than local
storage. With all these different
workarounds, you can make the pain
points of stateless authentication go
away, but they still feel like hacks as
compared to a stateful authentication.
One more important piece of topic when
we are talking about authentication is
rate limiting. A very important
mechanism for securing your
authentication. Without rate limiting,
if you have set up your server, what
happens? An attacker, a malicious user,
they can try thousands of requests per
second, per minute, millions of billions
of requests for trying different
different kinds of password, different
different combinations of username and
passwords on your server on your
authentication endpoint. And since you
are not limiting the rate at which a
particular user can make API calls or
send you requests, all of these go
through. Now from this two things can
happen. One, they are [snorts] able to
find a match and get access to a user's
account which is very bad or second they
send such a volume of requests to your
server that your server cannot handle
the load of all these requests per
second and your server crashes. This is
also bad. So rate limiting is obviously
a very important and a mandatory
security mechanism for your
authentication workflow and also your
other endpoints some kind of global
endpoint and the general practice is you
should be more restrictive when it comes
to your rate limiting configurations for
your authentication workflows for your
authentication endpoints and you should
be a little more generous when it comes
to your other endpoints. So the
configurations for rate limiting uh
differs whether it is your
authentication endpoint or your general
service endpoints. Since we are talking
about authentication, it is also
recommended to have multiple layers of
rate limiting not just a very simple
straightforward rate limiting strategy
for your authentication endpoints. uh
first layer usually is per IP rate
limiting which means that you limit how
many login attempts can come from a
single IP in a given time frame maybe
something like 10 attempts per minute.
This will help you stop automated
attacks. But there are some problems
with per IP based rate limiting because
in a lot of organizations, universities,
the outgoing IP address might match of
different different users who are trying
from different different devices because
all of them go through the same hop. So
that will not give you the correct rate
limiting metric all the time. And even
if you don't consider that with the
modern network infrastructure at current
times, attackers have techniques to use
multiple IP addresses using things like
botn nets or proxy networks, VPNs or
rotating IPs. There are a lot of
exploiting techniques. So IP based
limiting does not really work to
mitigate advanced attacks. So another
strategy that you can implement is per
account locking or per account limiting
which means you limit how many failed
attempts can happen for a single
account. So maybe like five failures per
15 minutes should log the account for 24
hours unless they contact the support.
So this will help you stop attacks that
rotate IP addresses or target a
particular account. But for this if the
attackers use another clever trick which
is trying one password let's say
something like 1 2 3 4 5 and they try
this one password across different
accounts. So one attempt at account A
one attempt at account B and so on. In
that case your per account limiting or
per account locking will not work. And
since they're anyway using multiple IP
address, multiple IP addresses, your
first layer of rate limiting which is
per IP rate limiting that will also not
work and this attack will go through. So
for this the last resort that you can
implement is global rate limiting which
means that how many login attempts your
system can take in a given time frame or
how many failed login attempts your
system can take in a given time frame.
So even if the attacker uses multiple IP
addresses and tries a single password
across a lot of accounts and for your
global rate limiting you have configured
that in your whole system in 1 minute
you will only allow let's say 100
attempts per minute your whole
systemwide in that case the moment the
attacker process the number 100 for
their attacking attempt for your
password brute forcing your system will
raise an alert and you will be able to
flag that incident and you can actively
try block all those IP addresses. You
can try showing capture to all your
users to filter out all the genuine
users from the malicious users etc etc.
Using this layered approach of rate
limiting you can prevent two things. the
attackers getting access to the account
of a genuine user through brute forcing
and your servers crashing because the
thousands of requests per second the
attacker is sending to your server. So
rate limiting is obviously a very
important strategy whenever we are
talking about security. We talked about
authentication. Now it's turn for
authorization. Again, if you want to go
deep into authorization and the
mechanics of it, please watch the
authentication and authorization video
separately. This is solely focused on
the issues, the security issues related
to authorization. And we already
discussed the security issues related to
authentication. To briefly explain,
authorization basically means while
authentication means the identity of the
user to identify which row in our
database, which row in the users table
in our database is associated with the
user who is trying to access our system
currently. The same way when we say
authorization it basically means after
we have identified the user after we
know exactly which user we are talking
about. The next step is what are the
permissions of the user? What are the
activities that the user is allowed to
perform in our system in our web app and
in turn in our back end that's basically
the difference between authentication
and authorization. Now the confusion and
when I say confusion I don't mean the
obvious confusion which is confusing the
definition between authentication and
authorization. I'm pretty sure any
engineer can easily understand what is
the difference between these two. But
the confusion that happens in a
technical implementation between
authentication and authorization that's
where most of these vulnerabilities
arise that is related to authorization.
For example, I'll take a very realistic
scenario that I often see in code bases.
Most probably we have already discussed
all these things. But we have a routing
layer. This is the first entry point of
our backend system. From routing layer,
we go to handlers which deals with
things like request body parsing and
validation and passing all the validated
data to our service layer. And our
service layer interacts with our
repository layer. Okay. So usually what
happens we place our authentication
middleware which is like require o
something like this. We place this at
the routing layer after finding out
which route the user is trying to access
because for login routes and for some of
the public routes we do not need the
user to be authenticated. So depending
on what routes the user is trying to
access, we place this middleware which
checks if it is stateful authentication,
the presence of the cookie with the
session ID and the validity of that. And
in case of stateless authentication, it
checks for the JWT token in the
authorization header and the validity of
that. If there is something wrong in
there, it throws either 401 403 back to
the user asking the user to properly
authenticate. Now this happens at the
routing layer. After this point, what
happens? The confusion arises here. The
confusion is once the user is
authenticated, we have this false sense
of security that now that we know the
user is our own platform's user and we
already have the data about the user, we
have already authenticated the user. Now
the user is allowed to access any parts
of any of the systems, right? The
handler, any kind of handler, any kind
of service, any kind of repository. Of
course, we place some very obvious
authorization related checks also at the
routing layer, which is things like if
the user is a member or the user is an
admin or the user is a super admin etc
etc. Or if we go a little bit more
granular, if the user has access to the
read permission on the entity books, if
the user has access to write permission
the entity books, things like that. If
we are going more granular on the
authorization layer. Okay, again that is
still at the routing layer but the
confusion the security vulnerabilities
that arise at the service and deposit
layer because because let's say at our
routing layer we have a require o
middleware which properly authenticated
the user. We checked that the user has a
proper session ID in the cookie and the
user is authenticated. In the next
layer, we also check the authorization
of the user which is the user has the
permission of read books is a granular
permission which states that this
particular user has the permission to
have read access on the entity books in
our database. Okay. Now finally we let
the user pass to our handler layer
service layer repository. Now the API
the particular endpoint that the user is
trying to access is this one / books
with a search parameter which says id
equals to something like five. Now what
is happening here in our web app in our
front end we have an interface here
where we are showing a list of books to
the user and there is a search bar here
and there are some filters here and in
the filters there is one particular
filter where they can pass multiple book
ids here and we will only show the
details of those books here. We will
only show the books in the table which
matches one of these ids. Since the user
selected or passed the ID five here our
front end made an API call and this is
the API for that which is /books in a
search parameter we are saying ID equals
to 5. And this again at the first entry
level it hit our routing layer. We check
the authentication check the
authorization with the granular
permission. And finally in the service
method we call the repository layer and
this is the final query that we ran
which is select star from books where id
equals to this is the final query we run
and whatever the result that we got we
returned back to our front end and the
user was able to see here. Okay that was
the whole experience. Now the problem
here is yes this part the problem was
this particular book id the book number
five this is not a resource and not an
entity which was created by the user for
which the user has access to which means
the book five is not of this user but
since they pass this particular ID in
the filter and we call the API and since
in the API layer we are not doing an
authorization check. So what we should
have done is after this query we should
have wrote and user id equals to what is
context dot user ID. Whatever user ID
that we were able to fetch at our
authentication reader we store it in our
request context and we have to match
that in our database query to make sure
that we only return the books for which
the user has access to. Now this is the
kind of confusion that I'm talking
about. Just because the user was able to
pass the authentication check, just
because the user was able to pass
authorization check of having read
access to books does not mean they have
access to all books in our system. So in
our database layer for every single
query we have to deliberately think what
are the entities exactly that the user
has access to. on a high level uh
because of this kind of confusion a lot
of authorization related vulnerabilities
arise. So let's talk about a a few
famous ones for which we have already
named those vulnerabilities. The first
kind of vulnerability is broken object
level authorization or in short BA. Now
this vulnerability which is called
broken object level authorization. This
is exactly the scenario that I mentioned
above. Just a fancy way of describing
it. Which means that our system does not
check the authorization of a user on
entities on database level. It just
checks the authentication and
authorization during our routing layer
but does not check it at our repository
level. So that kind of scenario can
cause this vulnerability which is called
broken object level authorization. Now
this scenario I explained sounds a
little harmless but someone with more
technical knowledge what they can do
they can write a script they can iterate
through all possible ids of books in our
system but instead of books it can also
be invoices or payment related
information in our database and they can
download every single invoice from our
system they can get a hold of all users
financial data and they can also modify
they can also tamper with the invoice
URLs uh account numbers etc. A lot of
damage can be done if we are not careful
about broken object level authorization.
So how do we actually fix this? How do
we fix BA? As I have already mentioned,
the fix is pretty simple, pretty
intuitive, which means that even though
we check authentication at the routing
layer, even though we check
authorization at the routing layer for
entity level, which is read invoices,
for example, in our repository layer, in
our service layer, we also have to make
another check, which means that don't
just fetch invoice number five, don't
just fetch book ID with ID 5. fetch
books or fetch invoices with ID5 and
where the created user ID or the user ID
also matches the user ID that we were
able to extract the authentication layer
which means we stored the user ID in the
context and we have to match that in our
database query. So what we are saying
instead of just fetching the book with
ID 5 we are fetching the book with ID 5
which also belongs to this user or which
also can be accessible to this user. We
are mindful about authoration till the
last point of access which is the
repository layer. We don't end up with
our false sense of security from the
routing layer. We have to take it all
the way towards our repository. That's
the way to prevent this broken
authorization issue. Now the second
important thing which is a very subtle
thing here is and I have seen this in a
lot of real world systems is backend
engineers they try to provide a very
good user experience because they are
only thinking about the happy path about
their own front end they don't entertain
the scenario of an attacker trying all
these combinations so some engineers
what they do when they get an API
request let's say with invoice ID 5 an
API which is supposed to fetch the
invoice invoice details with the id
five. So what they do they try to fetch
the invoice details with some kind of
dbquery db.query something something and
they find this particular invoice
entity. Then at the next step what they
do they check if the context dot user is
equals to invoice dot user ID they have
this condition. If this condition does
not match they throw an 403 error which
means forbidden. Now technically this is
right. We are supposed to throw 43
errors, forbidden errors whenever we
have an issue related to authorization,
whenever we have an issue related to a
user not having access to a particular
entity. But the problem with this is if
we return 403, if we return this
particular response which is forbidden,
we are confirming the fact that this
particular invoice, the invoice number
five, which the attacker, if they have
malicious intention, they most likely
have guessed. They don't know for sure
that this particular ID exists or not.
they have guessed this ID and they're
trying to verify if they can get access
to this invoice or at least they can
make sure this particular invoice exists
in our system so that they have other
ways to get an access to it. The moment
we throw a forbidden error, we are
saying that this particular invoice
exists in our system but we will not
give you access to that. Even though you
did prevent an attack there but you also
did some amount of information leakage
which can also be destructive over the
long run because if you are following
this pattern then an attacker can come
up with a list of ids 5 17 18 whatever a
list of ids and they can enumerate they
can call your API in a loop and they can
find out these are all the invoices that
exist in the system so that they can go
ahead and plan another layer of attack
something like social engineering attack
which involves interacting with humans
fooling humans and tricking humans into
extracting sensitive details from our
system and that is the reason another
important point that we have to keep in
mind is when it comes to authorization
related checks we have to be a little
more reserved about it. So ideally in
this scenario when we get a API call for
an invoice with ID 7 ideally what we
should check instead of checking the
existence of this invoice in one
database query and then checking if the
user has access or not then throwing a
403 forbidden error. Instead of doing
all this simply what we can do is we
just write a very simple SQL query which
just say select star from invoices where
id equals to 7 and user id equals to
whatever context dot user ID and when we
run this since this particular invoice
this does not belong to this user what
we'll get no rows and when we get no
rows error by default what we do we
return a 404 which is not found not
found response code back to our client.
And since we return not found as a
response for this particular query, the
attacker, they cannot tell the
difference between an invoice that does
not exist in our system versus an
invoice that exists in our system but
that belongs to someone else. If they
can make sure if they can verify point
number two, they can resort to other
layers of attack. Other layers of attack
which is mostly social engineering. Now
that they cannot differentiate between
these two, they cannot tell if the
invoice exists in our database in the
first place which in turn helps
preventing the other layers of attack
since we stopped them at the root level
without giving them any kind of
information. Now this whole thing this
authorization check database query level
this needs to happen not just for select
queries not just for view queries where
we are returning information.
[clears throat]
This needs to happen for any kind of
database query which is either edit
which means update or delete or insert
any kind of database query that we run.
We need to check this authorization of
the user at the database level without
leaking any information. That is also an
important. Now another similar
vulnerability another similar
vulnerability here is broken function
level authorization. Now this is pretty
much similar to the above vulnerability
which is BA and object level
authorization but this has a different
angle. So this is more about restricting
the access to functions as compared to
restricting the access to data which is
about this DFL is about functions and
what kind of functions do we mean are
sensitive functions especially the
functions which are only supposed to be
accessed by our admins. Let's say we
have an endpoint which is something like
/ admin/invoices
again. Now this particular endpoint is
only supposed to be accessed by the site
admin so that they can review different
different invoices. They can provide
support to the clients whenever there is
some kind of issue related to an
invoice. Now for this particular
endpoint we cannot do this which is this
pattern select star from invoices. We
cannot put a condition here which is
where id equals to five user id equals
to context dot. We cannot do that here
because the admin needs to see all the
invoices of our system. There should be
no wear condition. Even if there is a
wear condition it should be only for
filtering like active invoices or
pending invoices etc etc. There should
be no authorization related checks here.
For that reason this is not a object
authorization related vulnerability.
This is a function authorization
vulnerability which means that let's say
we have an admin panel here and in this
admin panel we are listing all the
invoices by using this type of API which
fetches all the invoices of our system
and shows it to our admin. Now one
clever trick that we did was we did not
share this URL which is safe do web.app
app whatever is your URL is you did not
share this particular URL with anyone
only the admin knows this URL but apart
from that you don't have any other kind
of security mechanism here if the admin
knows this URL and as long as the admin
is a user of our platform they can go
into the admin panel they can login as
usual the login flow is same for a
regular member and the admin the only
difference is the URL the access to the
URL once any user is able to login into
the admin panel they can call this
particular API and they will be able to
see all the invoices of our system. Now
again this sounds a little stupid but
these kinds of vulnerabilities still
happen in legacy systems where people
try to provide security through
obscurity. This is a very famous phrase
in the world of web security which means
that instead of providing actual
security instead of providing robust
security what you do you just hide
information you just do clever tricks
and you just do a lot of assumptions and
you just feel this false sense of
security that your system cannot be
accessed by malicious users or
attackers. This is exactly the same
case. Just by assuming that no other
user has access or knowledge about this
URL, our API is safe or our admin panel
is safe. That is not the case. This
whole setup can backfire. As long as
someone monitors your internet traffic
and the moment they see this particular
URL and they find out that there are no
admin level checks in your system, they
can call this API independently and they
can get a hold of all of your invoices
in your system. The mitigation to this
is something that we have already
discussed. The routing layer we perform
authentication and after authentication
we also need to perform authorization
and in the authorization we not just
check the granular permissions in this
case which is read invoices which is in
our case true. A user who is trying to
access their invoices, they also have
read invoices permission. And a user who
is trying to access all information,
which is the admin level function, they
will also have this same permission is
read invoices. The only difference is
the user role. So this user is a normal
user which is something like member and
the admin will have a role something
like admin. So another middleware should
be present here. Not just our permission
middleware, also the role middleware
which makes sure that the user that is
requesting access to this function which
is requesting access to this particular
API has the role of admin. They are
authorized to access this particular API
as admin. Then only we let them call
this function and then only we return
all the invoices of our system. That is
how we prevent broken function level
authorization. Another interesting
vulnerability here is indirect object
references and broken access control
patterns which talks about using
sequential ids of your database which is
something like 101 102 103 and using
these in your APIs something like
/invoices
slash 1 02 to fetch the invoice
information of this particular invoice.
Using this pattern enables
[clears throat] attackers to guess all
the other invoices in our system, the
existence of all the other 101 and 103
109 and so on. Since our ids are
sequential, since they are predictable,
they are prone to all kinds of attacks,
all kinds of enumeration based attacks.
As long as the attacker can predict the
existence of all these invoices in a
system, they can plan more number of
attacks targeting these. One prevention
to this is using uu id as our primary
key which is looks something like this
here. These are randomly generated and
often used as database primary keys.
They're also URL friendly etc etc. But
using UID also comes with a a couple of
performance related issue that you have
to read about. But generally UIDs are
recommended for this. Okay. Now that we
have discussed all this stuff about
authorization, try to cover two
summarizing points which will cover all
these vulnerabilities in a very simple
manner. After discussing all these
vulnerabilities related to
authorization, we can categorize the
authorization related attacks into two
types. One is horizontal authorization
attacks. The other one is vertical
attacks. Now this is a very simple
mental model a very simple mental
framework that you can use instead of
memorizing all these different
vulnerabilities related to
authorization. You can just think it in
a very intuitive way. First
[clears throat] is horizontal. Now
horizontal authorization attacks involve
user A getting access to the resources
of user B due to some incapability some
kind of linkage in our system. is
usually happens because we ignore
authorization at the database level and
we call it horizontal authorization
attack because the scope widens here. We
talking about different different users.
The scope widens here at a system level.
That is one kind of attack and under
this we have a broken object level
authorization that we have discussed and
this is also called ID or something like
indirect object reference. Both of them
mean the same thing. Now what is
vertical authorization attack? This is
the other case that we discussed which
is BFLA which means a user after
entering into our system instead of
widening their scope horizontally what
they do at our system level they widen
their scope vertically which means
getting access to more of our systems
resource instead of other users which
was the case when we talked about admin
level scenario. So after entering into
our system, a user is able to get access
to the functions sensitive functions
which are only accessible to an to an
admin user. So these are the two
categories of authorization related
attacks that we just discussed. Now to
discuss the framework, how do we
actually mitigate how do we actually
prevent all these authorization related
attacks? First thing is you need to
centralize your authorization logic. You
should not scatter your authorization
related checks throughout your codebase
where they'll be applied inconsistently
or or they are prone to getting
forgotten. So you should have a clear
authorization layer from where every
single request passes through right all
your logic related to authorization live
in the same place so that it is easy to
understand by all engineers in your team
and it is easy to maintain and it is
easy to scale. Second thing is a very
simple framework which is called default
deny which basically means that once you
have your authorization layer the
framework that you should follow is if
your authorization logic does not
explicitly allow something does not
explicitly allow certain permission
certain user role or whatever then you
should by default deny it. Instead of
checking the other way around, you
should deny any other kind of conditions
which is not explicitly allowed in your
logic. This way what happens when you
add new resources in your database or
new endpoints in your routing layer,
they are protected by default. Even
though you forget to grant access to
them in your authorization layer, but
until you do that, they are protected by
default. Now that is a very important
safety mechanism. Third thing, test
authorization specifically which means
that don't just test your happy parts. A
normal user, a benign user, a genuine
user is able to go through the whole
workflow correctly and you move on from
there. That is not how you should be
building systems. You should also test
for the edge cases which means that user
A should not be able to access the
resources of user B. Same way a regular
member role user should not be able to
access the functions of a user with the
role of admin or an unauthenticated user
should not be able to access any kind of
authenticated resources in your system
and should not test these things
manually. You should have automated
tests in your system. a dedicated test
just for authentication authorization
which checks for all these use cases
because if you test all these scenarios
manually most likely there will be some
change in your system someday which will
break one of these functionalities and
since you are manually testing all these
things. It cannot be as comprehensive as
automated test and you'll miss one of
these scenarios and that will leave a
huge security hole in your system. If
you have an automated test suite, every
time a new change is added to your
system in your CI/CD pipeline, all these
authentication and authorization related
test suites are run. And you can be rest
assured that your system is still secure
as the day you build your authentication
authorization system, no matter how many
additional changes are added to your
system over the time. And the last thing
is audit logs. Every time a sensitive
resource something like an admin
endpoint is accessed you should log that
in your audit table that this particular
endpoint was accessed at this time stamp
by this particular user etc etc. Same
way every time an authorization check
fails when a user tries to access the
resources of user B you should flag that
incident and you should log that as a
breach event dedicated because if there
is someone who's trying to probe your
system if there is someone who is trying
to break your system you should have the
knowledge of that so that you can take
advanced preventive measures for those.
Okay. Now that pretty much covers all
the things that you should know when it
comes to authentication and
authorization. Moving on to our next
major vulnerability which is XSS. It
stands for crossside scripting. Now we
are going to see a small demo of this
towards the end of this video. So before
that we'll just briefly explain what
this vulnerability means and how does it
work as how to prevent it and we'll
actually see it live in the demo. to
explain crossite scripting. It means
that when a malicious user or an
attacker [clears throat]
they manage to get their JavaScript any
JavaScript code or any JavaScript
snippet to execute in a user's browser
in a genuine users browser in the
context of your platform in the context
of your front end then this whole attack
is called cross-sight scripting. It's
still not clear how does it work and why
it is so dangerous. So let's cover that
part first. Why is it actually
dangerous? So we all know that
everything that happens in our browser,
all the processing that happens to
JavaScript. Any kind of computation that
runs and JavaScript in the context of a
browser can do a lot of things. It can
read everything that is happening on a
page as long as it has the context of
that page including the sensitive data.
It can also make API requests to a
remote server by impersonating as the
logged in user because they have access
to the cookie. They have access to the
local storage. As long as it is not HTTP
only, they have access to the cookie.
They can also redirect the user to other
pages, pages like fishing pages to fish
the credentials of the user. And lastly,
they can also alter or they can also
change the content of the page to trick
a genuine user into thinking the website
that they are looking at is a completely
different website. To summarize, if an
attacker manages to run their code,
their JavaScript code in another user's
browser exactly as it sounds like, it
can be very destructive. Let's look at
how this is possible in the first place.
The first kind of excss attack that we
can talk about is stored excss and this
is how it works. Let's say you have a
blogging platform and in that platform
you have a discussion board a comment
system discussion board where users can
come and they can post their comments
and other users can reply to that
comment etc etc. So if you are aware of
how markdown rendering works in SPS or
in client side JavaScript based
applications usually if we want to
support markdown in some kind of input
then what happens the user writes their
comment in markdown let's say they use a
hashtag to start an heading so that this
is a comment then they use hyphens to uh
write bullet points etc etc And when we
preview this or when we try to render
this as markdown, what we do? We use
these libraries, if we are talking about
the React ecosystem, the most popular
client side libraries for interactive
web apps, then what happens? This gets
converted into HTML using different
different libraries like Remark, Rehype,
and they have a plug-in based
architecture. So you can customize how
this looks and how to style it etc etc.
But this is the whole idea. The user
writes their markdown in the input and
to show that markdown. You convert it to
HTML and you provide some kind of
styling and you render that HTML by
injecting the HTML directly into your
DOM node. So we just take that and
inject whatever in a div or something
like that and whatever the user has
typed bullet points they will be
converted to something like lists. So an
unordered list starting the tag here li
first point li second point etc. Then
closing the unorder list tag here. So
the markdown gets converted to this
particular HTML and we actually have to
go ahead and inject this into the DOM so
that it can be rendered and we can see
what the user intended us to see. Even
though if you are using these popular
libraries like Remar, Hype and React,
all the safety mechanisms are already
taken care of. But assuming that you are
in a scenario where you are doing all of
this yourself or maybe we are talking
about a legacy system where the user
types some kind of markdown or some kind
of HTML and you render it by injecting
that into the web page and to store it
you send the whole converted HTML to
your server and the server in our
database and the next time the server
fetches the server sends it back and the
client injects that and shows us in the
comment list. Now a malicious user what
they can do if they want somehow by
tampering with the behavior of this
markdown to HTML conversion and finding
a hole somewhere they are able to inject
a script tag somewhere inside the HTML
and since we are taking the whole thing
and injecting into the DOM what happens
this script tag it starts getting
executed as genuine JavaScript code in
the context of our platform since that's
where this script is injected and that
is the reason if [clears throat] you
take a look at React and search for
dangerously set inner HTML come here in
the docs as you can see in order to
render this particular HTML what you
have to do in react is you have to pass
the HTML string inside a attribute which
is called dangerously set inner HTML.
The reactive has intentionally set the
name in a way that you are always warned
that when you are setting HTML like
this, you are on your own and you have
to be careful about XSS attacks since
there is a possibility that you are
injecting scripts into your web app. So
this particular vulnerability happens
not because of this practice for
injecting HTML into the DOM. that has to
be done. If you want to render
userdefined markup in our web app, then
we have to do some kind of injection.
But to prevent that what we should have
done, what the server should do is when
the server receives this particular
markdown, this particular markup
structure that the user has typed in the
form of a comment, it has to do a step
of sanitization, which means it has to
look for signs detecting if this can be
a potential exploit something like the
presence of script tag etc etc. So the
server can detect if a script tag is
present and it can strip that off and
only save the HTML. If the server does
not do that then your web app your
platform is prone to an XSS attack
especially a stored XSS attack because
every user who ends up viewing that
particular comment the script tag will
start running in their browser. Now the
moment the script starts running in
their browser, the attacker who has
written the script, they can send all
their session cookies, all their local
storage information to a server which is
controlled by the attacker and they can
view all those sessions and they can if
they want hijack those sessions also or
they can also retype the user to a
fishing page and steal their
credentials. So there is a lot of damage
that can be done here. So you have to be
very careful about whenever you are
injecting HTML structure into your web
app and you have to make sure that when
you're storing that user provided markup
you are doing proper sendation. There
are also different types of excss called
reflected XSS which deals with rendering
the script tag in your URL. There is
also DOM based XSS which is pretty much
the same as the scenario that we just
discussed setting the inner HTML
property of your web app. But to
summarize all these different kinds of
XSS attacks the cross site scripting
attacks all of them happen for a single
reason. The root cause for all of these
vulnerabilities is userdefined
content being treated as code rather
than data. Again, this is similar to SQL
injection attack where the
vulnerabilities happened because of the
confusion between code and data. And
accesss is pretty much the same but
instead of happening at the server layer
instead of happening at the SQL or
database layer it happens in the user's
browser. When a user provided data when
put into a particular languages context
in this case our HTML and JavaScript
combined gets treated as code instead of
what it was meant for which is data.
That is exactly when XSS attacks arise.
The easy prevention for this is
obviously sanitization in your
validation layer. Make sure whatever
user provided content that you are
dealing with that you're storing you are
properly sanitizing it before storing it
in your database. The point appears here
again that every time you are dealing
with user provided content. It does not
matter whether it is a user provided
search query. It does not matter whether
it is user provided HTML or an image
which can be of a very big size. Every
time you are getting something from the
user either you're storing it in case of
this or you are processing it using your
database or you are doing some kind of
file handling every time you're dealing
with users data you have to be very
mindful very careful about how you are
handling it. What kind of access you are
giving what kind of resources you are
spending on this particular operation.
If you do that then you can get out of
99% of vulnerabilities very easily.
Another prevention here and the
technical prevention is CSP is also
called as content security policy. Now
content security policy is provided by
your browsers. This is an HTTP header
which is sent by your server back to
your browser. And the purpose of this
particular SP header is your server
tells your browser exactly what kind of
resources it is supposed to execute and
what kind of resources it is supposed to
block. Okay, very clear instructions
about the what kind of resources it can
actually start executing, what kind of
resources it should trust. So you can
specify using your server things like
only run scripts from these specific
sources from these specific domains
which are coming from our domains or you
can specify that don't run inline
scripts at all. No inline script which
means our earlier attack which was
caused by injecting a script into our
DOM. this will completely get blocked
since you saying that don't run any kind
of inline scripts in the context of our
web app. So using CSP is also a very
robust fix for these kinds of situations
for dealing with XSS attacks. You can
also specify from what domains you are
supposed to load images from. If the
images are from a different domain then
you'll also get an error from CSP. so
that even if a malicious user is able to
inject some kind of script tag into your
browser, the browser will block it
immediately. It will not let it run in
that context at all. Now, one thing to
focus here is the CSP, the content
security policy that is provided. This
is not actually a prevention. This is
just one way to fight if you have any
kind of XSS vulnerability. The core
reason for which your site is vulnerable
to accesses that you have to fix
yourself first by properly sanitizing
your user provided inputs and
everything. But CSP is configured just
in case you forgot just in case there
was a very remote edge case which let an
excss attack to pass through. In that
case CSP can your last line of defense
but it is definitely not a prevention.
So you should be doing all kinds of
prevention and in the end you should
trust CSP to block any kind of attacks
that that passes through all your
defenses. There is another category of
attack which is called CSRF
also known as cross-sight request
forgery and I just want to mention this
very briefly because in my opinion CSRF
is not a major threat to modern web
applications. We cannot say that this is
non-existence because we still have
legacy systems. We still have outdated
practices in a lot of systems. But as
long as you are working with latest
technologies and using decent libraries
and frameworks, most likely you are not
going to face CSRF attacks. But just to
cover it in theory, CSRF works because
of the cross site nature of cookies.
Basically when you visit a particular
website what happens? Your browser
stores cookies for that site. This
particular website and when you make a
request to that site your browser
automatically includes those cookies in
the next request. And this whole thing
happens even if the request originates
from a different site. For example, if
we take a realistic destructive
scenario, you are logged into your
bank's site and your browser, it has a
cookie for let's say bank.com and now
when you visit another site which is a
malicious site created by an attacker
and the domain is evil.com either
through a fishing link or any kind of
genuine web browsing and when you land
in this particular website there will be
a form which will get autosubmitted or
there might be some kind of image tag
with an URL that triggers some kind of
javascript which submits the form for
you. Now this evil.com it will trigger a
code snippet where evil.com is making a
request to bang.com and since it is your
browser which is making the request to
bang.com even though the context is
evil.com from where you are originating
this request from but it is still your
browser and that is the reason your
browser will include the cookie or
bank.com in this particular request and
since the cookie was included the server
of bank.com it will see the request as a
genuine request and it will let it get
through and by using this whole workflow
the malicious user the one who created
evil.com they can perform some kind of
destructive actions but again as I have
already mentioned CSRF is not one of the
major threats that you should be
worrying about as long as you are using
modern technologies and modern libraries
another reason I say this is not a major
threat is because the same site cookie
config that we discussed in the
authentication section where It is
recommended that you always set this
either as strict or if your front end or
back end are in the different domains,
you can set it as lax. By default, our
modern browsers set the same site config
as lax. And unless your same site config
is none, you're by default protected
against the CSRF attacks. And the next
point of defense is our coarse config.
Now course is definitely not a security
mechanism but using course what happens
typically our backend they have course
configs and it checks if the request
that we are receiving it is coming from
a request that is own front end. If it
is not then we do not set the course
header and the browser of the client
blocks that particular request. Now that
is another not a very robust prevention
but it is still a line of defense
against CSRF attacks. So that's one of
the reasons worrying about CSRF attacks
does not make a lot of sense at least
with our current technologies, libraries
and frameworks. So we are just going to
mention it briefly and move on from here
to the next section. So far we have
mentioned and discussed different kinds
of vulnerabilities, how they work and
how to prevent them etc etc. Lastly, we
will discuss a few practices which can
turn destructive which can create
security holes in your system and how to
prevent those and how to think about
those. The first thing is
misconfiguration. Misconfiguration in
your system can also open a lot of
security holes. For example, let's talk
about secrets management. The most
abused concept in back end secrets
management. And when we say secrets, we
mean things like API keys or database
passwords or encryption keys or JWT or
whatever technology that we are using or
authentication secrets or secret. So one
obvious security vulnerability is which
I don't think anyone does these days is
storing any kind of secret in our source
code, right? which gets committed into
git and that in turn lands in GitHub or
Bitbucket or GitLab whatever version
control system that you're using. And
the moment that happens, everyone who
has access to your GitHub repository,
your Bitbucket repository or your GitLab
repository, they can now see all your
secrets. They can access your database.
They can access all your external
services using the API keys. They can
also mess with users data using the
authentication secrets and the
encryption keys. So making sure all your
secrets always live in environment
variables either using things like or
using some kind of external secret
management like AWS parameter store or
vault is from hashior etc. There are a
lot of services these days. So always
make sure any kind of secret does not go
into your version control system. Even
if a secret gets leaked into your VCS or
your GitHub and you go ahead and delete
that, that is still in your commit
history. Someone who goes back in the
commit history, they can still access
that particular secret. So the moment
you accidentally commit your secret into
your VCS into GitHub, you should go
ahead and rotate that secret or delete
that secret and create a new one. Okay,
one of those things that you have to
keep in mind when you're talking about
security. The second kind of
misisconfiguration that we should talk
about is debug mode in production in our
live environment. Typically when we are
developing in our local writing code in
our local our logging mode our logging
mode is set at debug level. What that
means is we log all kinds of data in our
in our standard output things like very
detailed error messages with stack
traces. Now stack traces itself contain
a lot of information about how our
functions are named, how our files are
named, how our code is structured etc.
Same way we also print a lot of
information about our databases. Things
like the explicit SQL query, the
database P configs, the database
transaction related information, all
these things that get printed in our
local standard output or in our local
terminal. Ideally when we go to
production the log level is set to info
which means we only log the information
related stuff for our production server
which means all these things the error
stacks the database query logs and the
whatever debug logs that we are printing
for example users sensitive information
etc etc all these things they never show
up in production logs they are only
meant for our local as long as our log
level is set to debug That's only when
they'll show up otherwise they'll never
get printed. But if we don't configure
the log level specifically at info level
and anything which is not debug level in
our production in our live environment
all these informations are all these
information are going to show up in our
logs and if and when log production logs
get breached the attacker can get a lot
of information about how our code is
structured what are the sensitive data
about the user what is the sensitive
data about database etc. So it is
important that you are mindful about
your log levels. What is the log level
of your production environment? What is
the log level of your local environment?
And what is the log level of your
staging environment? That is another
misconfiguration that can cause a
security hole in your system. The third
one is security headers. Security
headers. Now when it comes to security
headers, we have already talked about
CSPs which tell your clients what kind
of JavaScript it can execute in your
platform's context. There are some other
HTTP headers which help us prevent a lot
of security related issues. Things like
frame options which when properly
configured it prevents other sites,
other websites to embed our website
inside an iframe and which in turn helps
our users from being the victim of
fishing attacks. Because if we do not
properly configure Xframe options, an
attacker can configure our website and
they can show our website inside an
iframe. But using a technique called
clickjacking or any kind of other
JavaScript code that is running behind
the scenes, they can capture the user's
credentials and they can do a lot of
stuff depending on the users interaction
on that site. Since the site itself is
in control of the attacker, but in an
separate iframe they are hosting our
website. There are a lot of different
kinds of attacks that can be planned
there. Similarly, there are other
security headers and these days pretty
much all the web frameworks does not
matter whether you are using NodeJS,
Express or Golang, Echo, Jin, Python,
Django, whatever web server framework
that you're using. All of them provide
radius security middleares which when
configured is just a oneline change. All
these industry standard security headers
are configured for you. you don't have
to manually configure each of them as
long as you use these modern middleares.
So that's pretty much all that I wanted
to discuss about security in the context
of back end. Now finally putting all of
this into perspective, what I want to
say is every vulnerability that we
talked about and there are others there
are hundreds and thousands other
vulnerabilities. They are all about the
same fundamental thing which is
boundaries. So data crossing boundaries
between systems or between privilege
levels, between programming languages,
between different markup structures, any
kind of boundary. Whenever data crosses
any of these boundaries or any of these
trust zones, you have to be very
careful. We have to be very mindful
about what exactly is happening in your
system because every time we have
crossed a boundary, that's when we have
encountered a vulnerability. For
example, things like SQL injection where
untrusted input coming from the user
that crossed into the boundary of
database query language. Same way when
we were talking about XSS cross-ite
scripting that crossed the boundary of
users markdown into the boundary of
HTML. Same way for broken authorization
the requests cross the boundary of what
different users should access. So the
tip here is every time you're writing
code ask yourself where is data crossing
a boundary. What assumptions am I making
about the data? And what if those
assumptions are wrong? If you ask
yourself these three questions
repeatedly every time you encounter data
crossing boundaries then I can promise
you that you can avoid 99% of the
vulnerabilities that modern backend
applications suffer from. And another
thing is no single kind of defense is
perfect. So you always have to think in
layers. For example, your first layer of
defense and this I have stressed in so
many videos. It should be input
validation. Always validate every single
thing that is coming into your system
which is the first entry point for your
back end which happens after the route
is matched. At that point you have to
strictly validate every single thing
with as many conditions as possible. The
final data that leaves your validation
layer and reaches your handler layer
should be in exactly the structure that
you expect it to be. There should be no
surprises from that point on. That is
your first line of defense. The second
is parameterized operations. Always use
APIs that provide explicit parameters.
Whether we are talking about databases
or we are talking about OS level
functions like file operations etc etc.
Always use predefined framework defined
or your programming language defined
functions instead of just constructing
the commands by string concatenation.
Then authorization checks verify every
access at the point of access. Since for
the broken object level authorization
vulnerability what we did we verified
the authorization of the user at the
routing layer but the actual access was
at the repository layer and that's why
the vulnerabilities happened there. So
always verify the access at the point of
access. You have to be mindful about
where exactly the authorization point of
access is and you have to check the
access there instead of a couple of
layers upstream. Then security headers
and policies you have to configure your
browsers and your servers so that they
can limit the damage in case something
fails. For example, things like course
CSP and security headers all these
things they are not very robust defense
mechanisms. But in case some kind of
attack passes through your first line of
defenses, then these secondary
mechanisms can help you tone down the
scope of the attack. Then monitoring and
logging. Always monitor any kind of
suspicious activity and log them
properly. Send them to your login
service, raise alerts, etc. That should
be very obvious. And the whole point of
this is maybe there can be some kind of
weakness in one of these layers. But if
you have multiple layers of the security
then an attacker has to bypass all these
layers at once before they can cause any
harm to your system which has very less
amount of chances. So the last thing
that I want to mention is security is
not about learning a couple of
techniques or or a feature that you just
learn and go and implement. Security is
more about being paranoid about your
systems and the mindset that you bring
before writing every single line of
code. So always think about boundaries,
always think about assumptions. And one
last thing that I want to mention here
is if you want to learn more about
security explore in depth, there are two
resources that you can take a look at.
First thing is port sugar academy. Now
this is the company that has created the
tool which is called BSU which is a very
famous ethical hacking tool, penetration
testing tool and and this port sugar
academy has a very comprehensive catalog
about a lot of vulnerabilities how they
work with practical labs and the theory
behind it the computer science behind it
and everything. You can also recognize a
lot of vulnerabilities that we talked
about things like SQL injection
cross-ite scripting CSRF and clickjing
SSRF and OS command injection that we
talked about also authentication related
vulnerabilities oath related
vulnerabilities JT attacks and a lot
more that is beyond a video like this
that you can explore here and the best
part is all of this is completely free.
There are no charges, no hidden charges
here. I have personally learned a lot
about web security and security in
general from this particular resource.
So I hope you can spend some time and
learn more way more than what I was able
to cover in this particular video. Then
we have OASP a security focused
foundation and OASP top 10
vulnerabilities. It is a very famous
list of current setup vulnerabilities
that modern systems suffer from. They
keep publishing this list every few
years. So the current list is something
like this. On the top we have broken
access control which covers things like
BA, BFA, all these things that we talked
about. There is security
misconfiguration that we discussed and
an injection which covers OS command
level injection, SQL injections and a
lot of vulnerabilities and how severe
they are the real world instances of
those all of them are listed here. Now
there is a resource called OASP cheat
sheet which is again a very good
resource that you can take a look at to
learn about a specific concept. For
example, if we go to let's say
authentication here, then you'll find a
lot of information about what are the
good practices that you should follow
during authentication, what are the bad
practices, what are the security threats
that you should be aware of and they
cover a wide variety of domains when it
comes to security. Let's say if you go
to session management then here you'll
find a lot of important information a
lot of useful information about what are
the best practices what are the industry
standards that you should follow while
working with sessions how to manage
sessions the importance of session ID
why it has to be a cryptographically
secure pseudo random number generator
what are the conflicts of that and a lot
more information you can find a lot of
information for a lot of security
related I have personally gone through
all of these multiple times over the
years and this has been excellent in
building the security mindset by
covering different domains by keeping a
single goal in mind which is security
but coming at security from different
different domains that opens up a
completely new perspective in your mind.
So just wanted to share these two
resources with you because of course
this video by no means is comprehensive.
Security as I have already mentioned is
a very huge concept very huge domain.
The goal of this video was just to make
you aware of some of the things that you
should think about while building your
back end. And I have shared these
resources so that you can independently
do a lot more reading on security and
understand these concepts a lot more
deeply better than I was able to
explain. Okay, that's pretty much all I
had to say about security.